COMMITTEE SUB FOR AUSTIN
ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. DO THE
CONTINUE STAY HOME ORDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MATTHEW WORN IN
FISCAL DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. DO NOT HAVE A MASS WHICH
PROVIDE YOU WANT ONE FOR YOU WE
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
SERGEANTS KEY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR THE PUBLIC
TO THE ROOM. TODAY FORTY TWO OH
TWO WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF THE
LIMON NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA THE COMMAND TEAM SIX.
FEET A SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT FISCAL DISCIPLINE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITOL FOR
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF ANY
MEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WHAT PROVIDE TESTIMONY. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I'LL ASK
THE PUTS MICROPHONE DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT. I WOULD ASK THE
UBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CONNECTS THE
HEARING ROM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. TO BE SURE TO OBSERVE THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BE WILL TESTIFY FROM INSIDE
THE HEARING ROOM WHERE SOME
WITNESS. WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN THE CAPITAL A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOOKING THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS AND IN OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THOSE LOCATIONS CAN BE FOUND ON
OUR WEBSITE. THERE WILL BE NO
PHONE OPTION AVAILABLE FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASKING
QUESTIONS. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE'RE STEPPING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH SUBCOMMITTEES
EMAIL IT BUDGET SUB FOUR AT ASM
DOT CA DOT GOV THAT'S THE WORD
BUDGET THE NUMBER FOUR EXCUSE
ME. BUDGET WORD BUDGET AND THEN
SUB ISSUE BE FOR AND ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE ALL
FACE. THE FOCUS TODAY IS TO
HEAR UPDATES FROM EVD SINCE THE
LAST TIME THE SUBCOMMITTEE HELD
A MEETING ON THIS TOPIC.
SPECIFICALLY THIS COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE THE STEPS EDT HAS
TAKEN TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING OF UNPAID CLAIMS.
INCREASE COMMUNICATION WITH
PAYMENTS AND IMPROVE THE
OVERALL CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMITTEE WILL
DISCUSS ACTIONS THE
DESTRUCTIVENESS TAKEN SINCE ITS
INCEPTION NEARLY A MONTH AGO.
THE GOAL OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO WORK WITH THE AND THE STRIKE
TEAM TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS.
PROPOSE SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE
ANY ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT
MAY BE NEEDED. AS EXPRESSED IN
THE LAST SUBCOMMITTEE. HEARING
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK
THE RECORD FIVE EMPLOYERS EDT.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
PATIENCE AND COMMITMENT TO
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME TO THE
UNDERSTAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR
FRUSTRATION WITH EDT. ELECTRIC
CLOTHES THAT MEMBERS SAVE A
SPEC FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. ARE YOU TODAY THE
HARD STOP AT TWELVE NOON.
ANOTHER THIS LIMITS OUR TIME
DAY BUT DO COMPETING INTERESTS
AT THE END OF SESSION WE'RE
VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE A SECURE
TIME. FOR THIS HEARING. IS A
LIMITED TIME REALLY MAKING
TESTIMONY FROM REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. I PLAN TO REQUEST AN
UPDATE AFTER THE STRIKE TEAM
ISSUES ITS RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MAKE SURE WE HAVE EXTENSIVE
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS WE WILL
GIVE OPENING REMARKS. WE WILL
START OUR PANELIST. I RECOMMEND
THAT WE HEAR FROM OUR PANELISTS
NOW OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS FOR
THE QUESTIONS HOW DOES THIS
MEMBER THE MINDFUL OF OTHER
MEMBERS WERE WAITING TO ASK
QUESTIONS. LET'S BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR EDIE DIRECTOR SHARON
HILLIARD. MISSILE YOUR. AT.
THIS WEEK CAN YOU HEAR ME. BUT
WE CAN'T WE CAN'T HEAR YOU.
IT'S AWFUL. MISTER CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW. YES I CAN'T CAN YOU
HEAR ME JUST LIKE HIM YOU MAY
BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN COOPER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M SURE
UNTIL YOU'RE DIRECTORS
EMPLOYMENT AVAILABLE DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME BACK. I
AM HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE YOU A
PROGRESS UPDATE ON ED'S
RESPONSE TO THE HISTORIC
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIM
VOLUMES EXPERIENCE THE RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC. TODAY I'M
GOING TO TALK TO ABOUT
DEPARTMENTS HIRING PLAN GIVE
YOU ALL THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS.
AN UPDATE ON OUR CALL
OPERATIONS AND WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING WHAT WE'VE DONE WHAT
WE'RE PLANNING TO DO. AND
FINALLY AN UPDATE ON OUR CLAIM
PROCESSING A NUMBER OF ACTIONS-
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN AND ARE
GETTING READY TO TAKE- AS WELL
AS GIVE YOU A QUICK UPDATE ON
THE LOST WAGES ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. OF THE BEFORE I START
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW WHO IS
HERE WITH ME TODAY FIRST OF ALL
I HAVE- CAROL WILLIAMS SHE IS.
THE BRAND NEW CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER OPERATIONS AT THE
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME RECENTLY
APPOINTED. TODAY AS HER FIRST
DAY AND I HAVE TO SAY NO ONE'S
MORE EXCITED TO HAVE HER HERE
THAN I AM- I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ONCE AGAIN FOR BRINGING IN- A
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
WHETHER IT'S ALL THE
APPOINTEES. OR IS THE STRIKE
TEAM SO WELCOMED AND SO NEEDED
AND THANK YOU. I ALSO HAVE WITH
ME MICHELLE CERTAIN RATES SHE
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BRANCH
AND BETWEEN US- ANY QUESTIONS
THAT COME UP WILL BE GLAD TO
FEEL THEM. AND IF WE DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER WILL CERTAINLY GET
BACK TO ALL OF YOU. SO WITH
THAT- I PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE
THIS MORNING A PACKET OF
INFORMATION. OF CHARTS I
THOUGHT I WOULD PROBABLY BE THE
BEST WAY SO I CAN UPDATE YOU
AND YOU COULD ACTUALLY SEE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS AND THEN YOU LOOK AT
THE YOU HAD IT MOVING FORWARD.
YOU KNOW IN FULL TRANSPARENCY
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU HAD
EVERYTHING. SO I'M GONNA START
AND WALK THROUGH THESE JERKS-
THE FIRST ONE IS THE HIRING
STAFF DETAILS IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT. THIS IS THE STAFF%
REPRESENTED IN MONTHLY THAT
HAVE COMPLETED TRAINING AND
PRODUCTIVE SO WE'VE DISPLAYED
THE NUMBERS WHEN THEY'RE
ACTUALLY PRODUCTIVE NOT WHEN WE
HIRED THEM. TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
WE'RE WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
FINISHING UP HIRING ABOUT FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED. ORIGINALLY WAS
LOOKING AT FIFTY THREE HUNDRED-
I RECENTLY UPPED IT TO FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED TO- ADD MORE
RESOURCES IN THE WORK YOUR
PROGRAM- ALSO THOUGH I AM GOING
TO CONTINUE TO ASSESS THE LEVEL
RESOURCES AND WE MAY VERY WELL
AND I EXPECT. THAT WE'LL BE
DOING EVEN ADDITIONAL HIRING
BUT ON THE FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED-
THE WORKLOAD WARRANTS IT I
BELIEVE AND- WE JUST NEED TO
CONTINUE AND TAKE A LOOK AT IT
WHICH WERE CREDITED TO. SO I
SPLIT. THE CHART INTO TWO BOXES
THE FIRST ONE- REALLY FOCUSES
ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CALL CENTER STAFFING. AS YOU
KNOW THERE'S TWO LINES THERE'S
A YOU AYE SUPPORT CLAIM SUPPORT
WHICH IS OPEN FROM EIGHT TO
TWELVE AND THERE'S A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LINE IS OPEN FROM
EIGHT TO EIGHT. PANDEMIC WE HAD
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE AND ARE YOU AYE CLAIMS
SUPPORT- OUTLINE. A WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT LINE
THAT CAME AFTER THE PANDEMIC-
SOMETHING WE SET UP QUICKLY IN
A BRICK ON A VIRTUAL PLATFORM.
UP WHEN THE PANDEMIC CAT
BECAUSE IT WAS A TIDAL WAVE
BEYOND TIDAL WAVE OF WORKLOAD.
WE REDIRECTED TO LEARN FIFTY OF
THOSE STAFF- TO DO CLAIM
PROCESSING BECAUSE WE YOU KNOW
WE NEEDED TO MAKE PAYMENTS I
LEFT A HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE
PHONE. BUT WE CLEARLY RECOGNIZE
AND ARE THERE NOT ENOUGH NOT
ENOUGH TO FOR. CLEARLY NOT
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT CALIFORNIA SO DESPERATELY
NEEDS. ALL AND THAT IS WHY WE
ADDED THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
LINE- IN APRIL AND STAFFED IT
WITH- SOME REDIRECTED YOU AYE
STAFF ASWELL AS- TAFF FROM
OTHER PROGRAMS. AND ALSO
CONTRACTED WITH DELOITTE TO
BRING ON AGENTS QUICKLY- SO WE
COULD SCALE UP AS A TEMPORARY
MEASURE. AND THEN PROVIDED OF
DIFFERENT WHAT ABOUT TRAINING
SEVERAL TRAININGS INFORMATION
MENTORS THE WORKS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN MAKE THEM AS
PRODUCTIVE AND HELPFUL AS
POSSIBLE. FROM THERE YOU CAN
SEE WE OF BIG WE STARTED HIRING
AND TRAINING ACTIVELY EACH
MONTH WE'VE BEEN. ADDING MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE AND JULY FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE AUGUST SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE. OF SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR AND NOT KNOW
THOUSAND OCTOBER IF YOU CAN SEE.
IN OCTOBER- WE WILL BE
COMBINING OUR TO CALL CENTERS.
UP TO CALL LINES INTO ONE CALL
CENTER WHICH I'M EXCITED ABOUT
SO ALL THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
FOLKS WILL BE IN THE ONE CALL
CENTER AND FOURTEEN HUNDRED OF
THE FOLKS WILL BE OFFICE
TECHNICIANS THAT PROVIDE
GENERAL ASSISTANCE- YOU KNOW
CLUB- CLAIM UPDATE A PASSWORD
CHANGES- GENERAL INFORMATION.
AND THEN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVES TO WORK ON THE
MORE SPECIFIC COMPLEX CASES WE
CLEARLY SEE WE NEEDED A HIGHER
RATIO OF PROFESSIONAL STAFF
THAT CAN GET INTO THE MORE
COMPLEX ISSUES. GIVEN WITH THE
CARERS ACT- THE PROGRAMS ARE SO
COMPLEX AND WE NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE WE PUT ENOUGH RESOURCES IN
THAT THAT HIGHER LEVEL. WE ALSO
WILL HAVE- FIVE HUNDRED LOIT
AGENTS THAT WILL PROVIDE. SOME
GENERAL INFORMATION AS WELL
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THEM ON
CONTRACT THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR AND- IF WE DETERMINED
THAT- WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE FOR
AS FAR AS OUR RESPONSETHAT AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO- NOT RENEW THE
CONTRACT- BUT I WANT TO KEEP
THAT OPTION OPEN AND- LIKE I
SAID IT WILL BE ASSESSING EVERY
MONTH THE MAIN THING I WHAT
THE WORK. YET PROVIDING THE
SERVICE AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A GOOD FOUNDATION
BEFORE WE DISCONTINUED THAT
THAT SERVE THAT CONTRACT. SO
THAT'S THE BECAUSE CENTER BOX.
THE NEXT BOX BREAKS DOWN ALL OF
OUR WORK FUNCTIONS- BY WORK
FUNCTION SO YOU CAN SEE
EXACTLY- WHAT WE WORK STARTED
WITH THEN- WHERE ARE NOW. FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE CALL CENTERS
LIKE I SAID WE STARTED AT THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY OUT WE WILL BE
ENDING AT THE END OF THE YEAR
WITH THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE. AND I DO EXPECT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO ADD EEN DIGITAL
RESOURCES IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA I'M GONNA BE WATCHING THE
CALL METRICS. AND BASED ON THE
RESPONSE LOW RESPONSE WE MAY BE
ADDING MORE SO MORE TO COME ON
THAT. CLAIM FILING YOU'LL SEE
WE STARTED AT FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX. AND WE'RE NOW TO
ALMOST WILL BE ALMOST AT TWO
THOUSAND A CLAIMSFILER'S
IDENTITY WE STARTED WITH TWENTY
AND WE'RE GONNA END UP WITH
FIVE HUNDRED AND THREE PEOPLE.
A ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS WE STARTED AT
FOUR SIXTY AND WE'RE- GOING TO
END UP WITH THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE OF THAT WENT DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
WE HAVE BEEN UTILIZING THAT
WE'RE SO WE'VE BEEN DOING LAST
DETERMINATIONS TO HELP CLAIMS
GO THROUGH. QUICKLY UP RECALLS-
WE START WITH FORTY TO GO AND I
WERE AT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN I WILL TELL YOU ALSO WE
HAVE TURNED THE CORNER ON
RECALLS WE ARE NOW PRODUCING
ABOUT 35% MORE THAN- WHAT WAS
RECEIVING WHICH IS GREAT WE
THOUGHT YOU KNOW OF ALL THE
TRAINING AND- THAT SCALING AND
GETTING PEOPLE- MORE PEOPLE
HIRED- WE'VE CLEARLY COULD
CLEAR UP TURNED A CORNER SO WE
CAN. AGGRESSIVELY IT WORK INTO
OUR OLDER CASES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE BEING RESPONSIVE SO
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT WORK
SHARE RESTORED WITH FIFTY ONE
AND WE'RE NOW IT TOO CAN BE AT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY ONE. AND AN
OVERPAYMENT APPEAL SAID ABOUT
THE SAME AT THIS. OR NOT
FOCUSING ON OVER PAYMENTS AT
THIS AT THIS MOMENT AND WE'RE
FOCUSING ON GETTING PEOPLE PAID
WE ALSO HAD SIX HUNDRED FORTY
NINE- REDIRECTED STAFF- THAT
WORK ON SOME OF THE- CLAIMS
FILING AND CONTINUE CLAIM
SUPPORT. DOING SOME OF THE LESS
COMPLEX WORK WE HAVE A IN THOSE
AREAS. SO THOSE STAFF WILL
BEGIN TO TRANSFER BACK TO THEIR
PROGRAMS OCTOBER NOVEMBER
DECEMBER- AS YOU KNOW AS WE CAN
THE OTHER PROGRAMS OF IT THEN
EXTRAORDINARILY IN A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU I PROGRAM
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING BY THE U. I- AND OUR-CUSTOMERS SO AS WE CAN WITH
WHAT WE WILL- BE PEELING PEOPLE
OFTEN SO THEY CAN RETURN AND
GET CONTINUE TO HIRE IN THE
YOUR PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING. THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN. SO THAT'S HIRING
STAFF DETAILS I HOPE THAT GIVES
YOU A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING WHERE WE'RE GOING
AND- AND ALL THE NUMBERS AND-
OF COURSE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE NEXT CHART IS ON
CALL CENTER DATA. ARE YOU HAD
ASKED ABOUT THIS LAST TIME SO I
WANTED TO GIVE YOU AN ACTUAL
PICTURE AND SPECIFICS ON OUR
CALL CENTER DATA AND THE DATA
IS FOR BOTH LINES IT'S A
COMBINATION OF BOTH LINES AN IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CHART. UP CALLS
ANSWERED THE BLUE LINE IS
CALLED THE CALLS THAT WE
ANSWERED IN OUR ON OUR CALL
LINE. AND THE GOLD LINE IS THE
UNIQUE COLORS THE NUMBER OF
CALLERS THAT ACTUALLY- CALLER
CALL CENTER- IF THE INDIVIDUALS
VERSUS HOW MANY TIMES THEY
CALLED- YOU KNOW WE TRACK IT BY
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE ACTUALLY SERVICING-
BUT WE- TOTALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY'RE CALLING. THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT YOU KNOW
TIMES. UP REPEAT DIALING SO BUT-
ALSO THEN THE PERCENTAGE OF
CALLS ANSWERED SO PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WE WERE ANSWERING
ABOUT 54% OF THAT THE CLAIMS
OF- AT CALLS BY UNIQUE COLORS.
AND YOU CAN SEE ONCE THE
PANDEMIC HIT WE TOOK A NOSE
DIVE DOWN 2408% 8% 3% TO
PERCENT- IT THE TIDAL WAVE WAS
YOU KNOW JUST TOOK US OUT AND
BUT- WITH ALL THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND ON THE
STAFF RESOURCES AND WORKING ON
A CALL CENTER- YOU CAN SEE OVER
THE MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN
IMPROVING EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
WENT 21720% 27% 32% IN LAST
WEEK WERE AT 40% AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO CLIMB UP
AND I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT. I'M NOT SURE I WOULD LOVE
YOUR INPUT ON WHERE WE PROBABLY
SHOULD ULTIMATELY LAMP AN
INDUSTRY STANDARD USUALLY UP
FOR CALL CENTERS YOU WANNA
ANSWER ABOUT 80% OF YOUR CALLS-
AND STAFF IT THAT WAY BUT THAT
THAT MAY STILL NOT BE
SUFFICIENT BECAUSE IT ENDED
THEY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
WE'RE DRESSING EVERYBODY'S
NEEDS SO I WOULD LOVE. YOUR
INPUT AND FEEDBACK ON THAT
TOTAL COSTS IT'S NOT ON THE
SERVER JUST SO YOU HAVE IN CASE
YOU'RE INTERESTED. IN JULY A OR
EXCUSE ME IN MARCH APRIL WE
WERE LIKE AT. FOURTEEN MILLION
CALLS A WEEK. BY JUNE WE ARE
COMING DOWN ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION CALLS A WEEK AND MOST
RECENTLY WERE AT SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION CALLS A WEEK. SO
IT DEFINITELY IS- COMING UP
COMING DOWN- SO JULY WAS SIX
POINT SEVEN MILLION AND THEN
MOST RECENTLY FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION PER WEEK SO- SO THAT SO
MAKING PROGRESS THERE ON THE
CALLS ARE COMING DOWN. SO
THAT'S IT FOR THE CALL CENTER
BEGAN. WITH A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT WE- OPEN IT UP. THE NEXT
SLIDE IS FIRST PAYMENT
PROMPTNESS- WE PROVIDED OR I
PROVIDED THIS METRIC THE LAST
TIME I IN MY MEMO TO YOU OR TO-
SECRETARY SUIT THAT SHE
PROVIDED SO I WANTED TO GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON THAT AS WELL.
THE FIRST AREA I THAT I'M FOR
ALL UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS TYPE- I DID PROVIDE THIS
LAST TIME BUT I THOUGHT YOU
MIGHT BE INTERESTED. BECAUSE
THIS GIVES THE- FIRST PAYMENT
PROMPTNESS FOR REGULAR YOU LIFE
YOU WAY IF YOU SEE AN FED AT
ALL OF THEM. THE ONE I PROVIDED
LAST TIME ONLY SPOKE TO THE U.
I. PROGRAM. SO AS OF JULY
THIRTY FIRST 75% OF CLAIMANTS
HAVE RECEIVED THEIR FIRST
PAYMENT WITHIN TWENTY ONE DAYS
FROM THE TIME THEY SUBMITTED
THEIR YOU EYE ON LINE
APPLICATION. JUST SO YOU HAVE
THAT DATA. NOW THE OTHER
MEASUREMENT THE REGULAR REGULAR
ON. INSURANCE THAT IS WHAT- IS
REQUIRED BY DEAL WELL THAT'S
OUR MEASUREMENT AND WHAT THEY
REQUIREMENT REQUIRES STATES TO
PAY 87% OF ALL FIRST PAYMENTS
ON A REGULAR YOU AYE CLAIM
WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS OF THE
FIRST PAGE OF A WEEK. ENDING
DATE. WHEN THERE'S A WEEK
WAITING PERIOD OR WITHIN TWENTY
ONE DAYS WHEN THERE'S NO
WAITING PERIOD. WE DON'T HAVE A
WAITING PERIOD BUT WE STILL-
PROVIDE DATA AND LOOK AT THESE
MEASURES FOR BOTH FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE. M. LAST TIME I
PROVIDED YOU THE DATE IT WAS
THROUGH JUNE I'VE NOW ADDED TO
LIVE JUST RECENTLY CAME OUT.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT- EDIE'S
FIRST PAYMENT PROMPTNESS- WENT
UP- IN JULY TWO SIXTY POINT
EIGHT- AND THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
IS SIX SIXTY POINT. SO ABOUT
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE NOT NOT
MUCH BUT IT WILL BUT DEFINITELY
IMPROVED FROM LAST MONTH AGAIN
A DIRECT RESULT OF ALL OUR
HIRES. AND GETTING THAN THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDED RESOURCES ON
BOARD. AND THEN FOR THE TWENTY
ONE DAY MEASURE- WE'RE AT
SEVENTY TWO POINT SEVEN WHICH
WAS AN INCREASE FROM JUNE WHICH
WAS SIXTY FIVE POINT ONE
PERCENT- AND THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF SIXTY SEVEN POINT
USE OR- ABOVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE THEIR TO. SO GOOD NEWS
I WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU. WE
CAN DO BETTER BUT IT'S A GOOD
STARTING WE'RE DEFINITELY
SHOWING PROGRESS. OKAY. THE
NEXT CHART IS THE CURRENT%
STATUS OF CLAIMING DATA AS
REPORTED OF JULY TWENTY THIRD
ONE- IN MY MEMO- I- PROVIDED
YOU A DATA BY ALL THESE
DIFFERENT WORK STREAMS OUT OF
SEVEN TWENTY THREE SO THAT'S
WITHOUT A SECOND COLUMN IS THAT
REPEATED THE DATED I PROVIDED
YOU AGAIN BEFORE SO YOU CAN-
USE THAT AS A BASELINE AND THEN
SHOW. YOU CAN SHOW WHERE WE ARE
TODAY. OF THE STATUS OF AS OF
EIGHT TWENTY. THAT WHAT'S BEEN
PAID INCREASED- TO FOUR POINT
NINE WHICH WAS AN INCREASE OF
2% UNPAID WHAT IT WAS ONE POINT
TWO AND IT'S NOW ONE POINT OH
ONE WHICH IS A DECREASE OF 16%
IN ELIGIBLE WAS ONE SIXTY ONE
POINT SEVEN AND- AS OF EIGHT
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR. THOUSAND
WHICH IS- AN INCREASE OF 1% AND
THEN. MAYBE ELIGIBLE WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- IT WAS
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND AND WAS REDUCED TO
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND WHICH IS VERY GOOD
NEWS AND IF I BREAK OUT THAT
DOWN FURTHER. THOSE THAT HAVE
NOT CERTIFIED FOR BENEFITS THE
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN IS
NOW DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND. WHICH IS A DECREASE
OF 61% I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW WE
STARTED SENDING OUT REMINDER
EMAILS AND ENHANCE OUR
COMMUNICATIONS- TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY
NEEDED TO GO AND CERTIFIED. IN
IN ORDER TO- RECEIVE PAYMENT SO
CLEARLY THE EMAILS ARE ARE HOT
HAPPENING IN HELPING. ALSO FOR
THE FOR THE FOLKS THAT DID NOT
PROVIDE WAIT INFORMATION TO
QUALIFY FOR A CLAIM- WE WERE AT
THREE HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND AND
NOW WE'RE DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. SO AGAIN I THINK
THAT ENHANCE COMMUNICATIONS IS
DEFINITELY SHOW I'M SHOWING
RESULTS AND IT WAS THERE WAS A
DECREASE OF TWENTY TWO PERCENT.
SO I'M VERY VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT. AND THEN- ON THE PEN THE
WORK ITEMS THAT WE- I HAVE HAD
AND- AND OUR BUCKET. OF THE
PENDING EIGHTY RESOLUTION OR IS
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND. WE ARE NOW DOWN TO
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND. AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND THAT'S A MINUS THE
66% OF WE ARE US OF FOR THE
MARCH THROUGH JUNE- WORKLOADS
WE ARE ON PACE TO HAVE THEM
DONE BY THE END OF SEPTEMBER
AND- SO- PERCENTAGE WISE WE
HAVE COMPLETED ABOUT EIGHTY TWO
PERCENT. OF THAT WORKLOAD. NOW
pAN INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY SIX. SO ASK PEOPLE
STARTED CERTIFYING AND
PROVIDING US INFORMATION- THAT
MOVED TO DIFFERENT BUCKETS
WHETHER IT WAS UNPAID PAIN IN
ELIGIBLE OR- ACTIONS THAT WE
NEEDED TO TAKE. SO OF COURSE
YOU KNOW EVERY DAY IS A- IT'S
GONNA HAVE A DIFFERENT
INVENTORY BUT- IT THIS MEANS
THAT THEY TOOK ACTION AND NOW
WE NEED TO TAKE OUR ACTION IN
ORDER TO ON THOSE ALONG AND GET
THEM PAID. SO THAT INCREASE
THEIR- LET'S SEE ANYTHING ELSE
I WANTED TO SAY. OKAY GO TO THE
NEXT YEAR. SO THIS CHART IS ALL
THE ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
COMPLETED AND THE TURKS AFTER
THAT ARE THINGS THAT ARE UNDER
WAY. THE FIRST ONE- WAS IT- IF
YOU MAY REMEMBER WE RELAXED
ELIGIBILITY CONDITIONS SUCH AS-
LOOKING FOR WORK. LET'S A LET'S
OBVIOUSLY GIVEN IT'S TIME RIGHT
NOW THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
EMPLOYMENT OUT THERE SO WE ARE
RELAXED THAT REQUIREMENT. IN
WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO DO BASED
ON FEDERAL AND STATE GUIDANCE
AND OFFERED FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
PANDEMIC BETWEEN JUNE AND
AUGUST THE JUNE FIFTEENTH AND
AUGUST TENTH. WE ALLOWED-
FIFTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
ELIGIBILITY ISSUES TO BE
AUTOMATICALLY CLEARED RESULTING
IN FRONT PAYMENTS ALLOWING
STAFF TO FOCUS ON CRITICAL
WORKLOADS. SO WE IMPLEMENTED A
MARTIAN WE'VE BEEN DOING IT
CONTINUOUSLY TO PUSH PAYMENTS
PEOPLE. GET RID OF ISSUES AND
BE ABLE TO PUSH PEOPLE THROUGH
SO THEY GET PAID. WE ALSO
MODIFIED ARE YOU AYE ONLINE
CLAIM APPLICATION PROCESS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF AUTO
PROCESSING AND PLANES WITHOUT
STAFF INTERVENTION. AS OF JULY
THIRTY ONE WE HAD 69% OF
APPLICATIONS ARE FILED AN EASY
SYSTEM WITHIN- TWENTY FOUR
HOURS WE IMPLEMENTED THAT IN
APRIL AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS WELL. AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN- WE STARTED THAT
TEXT CAMPAIGN. BACK IN THE
SPRING WE HAVE NOW SENT OUT
OVER TEN POINT SIX MILLION TAX
AND THREE POINT SIX TO THREE
POINT SIX MILLION CLAIMANTS. WE
NEED A REMINDER EMAILS TO CLAIM
IT SAID I'M NOT CERTIFIED FOR
BENEFITS WE IMPLEMENT THAT GINO
WE CONTINUOUSLY DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE I THINK WE'RE
SEEING GREAT MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
GOING IN AND- NOW CERTIFYING
FOR BENEFITS. UP WE RELAX
EDUCATION TIMELINESS RULES TO
ALLOW CERTIFICATIONS TO BE
PROCESSED IS OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
UP TO A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
VERSUS THE TWENTY ONE DAYS. WE
FOUND THAT WAS REALLY WE'RE
HAVING A LOT OF PEOPLE NOT
COMING BACK IN PRIOR TO THE
TWENTY ONE DAYS AND THEN
THEY'RE HAVING TO REOPEN THE
CLAIM IT JUST BECAME VERY
CONFUSING. SO WE TOOK A LOOK AT
IT AND- CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY LAWS OR ANYTHING ANY REASON
LIKE WE COULDN'T CHANGE IT. AND
SO WHEN WE FELT WE FELT WE
COULD SO WE CHANGED IT A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. AND NOW IT- ALL THE
WAY UP TO A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
SO I THINK THAT WILL REALLY
HELP- REDUCE THE BURDEN ON
CLAIMANTS. ALSO WE ISSUED
REMINDER EMAILS TO CLAIMANTS
THAT HAVE NOT PROVIDED WAIT
INFORMATION WE JUST ROLL THIS
OUT THIS WEEKEND. SO MOVING
FORWARD NOW CLAIMANTS TO
PROVIDE WAIT INFORMATION WILL
BE SENDING. REMINDER EMAILS ON
THAT JUST LIKE WE'RE DOING FOR
MAKE SURE YOU CERTIFIED. SO I
THINK THAT WILL- HELP INCREASE
OF THAT POPULATION- AND HELP
THEM MOVE ALONG AS WELL. AND
THEN WE DEPLOYED- THE KNOWLEDGE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO MORE
QUICKLY ON BOARD MORE HIRES AND
INSURE MORE TIMELY GREATER
CONTINUITY. I RESPONSES
PROVIDED BY THE CALL CENTER. WE
ROLLED THAT OUT A- AUGUST WHEN
AND THAT'S A CONTINUOUS PROCESS
BUT IT'S OUR STAFF LOVE THAT.
OKAY. ATV ACTION PLAN UNDER WAY
THINGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW IN PROGRESS IS
ENHANCEMENT TO THE U. I. ONLINE
TO ALLOW CUSTOMERS TO UPLOAD
IDENTITY DOCUMENTS. WE'RE
EXPERIENCE SITE ABOUT THIS ONE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
DOCUSIGN- TERROR BUT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
EXPERTS AND WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WE'RE ON
SCHEDULE NOW TO IMPLEMENT
SEPTEMBER ONE TWENTY TWENTY I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW EXCITED BUT
WE'RE ABOUT THIS BECAUSE- TWO
THINGS WILL HELP IMPROVE THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE GREATLY.
THEY WON'T HAVE TO SEND THINGS
IN BY SNAIL MAIL AND- ALSO
INCREASE OUR PROCESSING OUR
ABILITY TO TURN THINGS AROUND.
SO THAT'S EXCITING. I IN
PROGRESS IS ENHANCEMENTS TO THE
U. I. LINE TO ALLOW CUSTOMERS
TO UPLOAD WAGE DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS ARE MISSING WAGES SO
WE'RE STARTING WITH A IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS AND THEN WE'RE MOVING
TO THAT WAGE DOCUMENTS. WE ALSO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
CLAIM STATUS OR TRANSITION-
TRANSPARENT YOU AYE ONLINE SO
CUSTOMERS HAVE VISIBILITY INTO
THE VERY FIRST. WE DO SEND-
HARD COPY NOTICES EXPLAINING IT
BUT IT'S NOT CURRENTLY ON ARE
YOU ON EXPLAINING THE REASONS.
AND OR ACTIVELY WORKING ON THAT
AND WE SHOULD FINISH DISCOVERY
US SEPTEMBER FOURTH AND THEN
DECIDE HOW HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT. WE'RE ADDING
A SKILLS BASED ROUTING TO THE
UPGRADED VIRTUAL CONTACT CENTER
TO ALLOW ESCALATED CALLS TO BE
TRANSFERRED IN TRAINED. CLAIMS
ARE PROCESSING STUFF THAT'S ONE
SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED AT THE
END OF THE MONTH. OR END OF
OCTOBER SKEWS ME. AND THEN- OF
COURSE WE'RE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STRIKE
TEAM TO FURTHER EXPLORE
TECHNOLOGY OPTIONS AND CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE I'M THRILLED ABOUT
THAT- THE WORKING WITH THEM
CLOSELY. I CAN SEE THEY'RE
GOING TO COME BACK WITH SOME
GREAT IDEAS TO FURTHER MOVE US
TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE AND
ENHANCING OUR CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE. THE LAST SLIDE. I
JUST WANTED TO BRING OUT THE
SINCE THIS IS A VERY CURRENT IS
THE LOST WAGES ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. IT WAS AUTHORIZED ON
AUGUST EIGHTH- BUT THE OTHER
PRESIDENTIAL MEMORANDUM. INA
APPROVED OUR APPLICATION ON
FRIDAY FOR FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION WHICH EQUATES TO ABOUT
THREE WEEKS OF SUPPLEMENTAL
BENEFITS. WITH THE POSSIBILITY
OF ADDITIONAL BENEFITS MOVING
FORWARD- THIS WILL BE AVAILABLE
STARTING FOR THE WEEK AT THE
AUGUST FIRST IS WHEN I'LL BE
ALLOWED. THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT WILL BE THREE HUNDRED A
WEEK- FOR A LIMITED TIME
PERIOD. A MINIMUM OF THREE
WEEKS- FOR CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE
PROVIDED SELF CERTIFICATION
THAT ARE UNEMPLOYED OR
PARTIALLY UNEMPLOYED DUE TO
DISRUPTIONS BY COVERT NINETEEN.
AND ESTABLISHED A WEEKLY
BENEFIT OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
MORE. BOB THIS IS N OUR
IMPLEMENTATION IS IN PROGRESS-
WE GOT ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE UP
LATE LAST NIGHT- SO WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THAT AND
FINALIZE OUR IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN. END DATE SO YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM US VERY SHORTLY
I'M NOT. AND THAT'S PRETTY MUCH.
MY REMOTE. AND I WANT TO TELL
HOW I AM I GET TO IT BRING THAT
SAYS. RICHARD THAT HAS BEEN
AMPLO THAT'S BEEN AHEAD OF THE
STRIKE TEAM WITH JENNIFER
PARKER. AND I GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THEY'RE
DOING AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
AND THANK THE HARD WORKING
EMPLOYEES OF EDIE. I KNOW HOW-
THEY CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
LIVELIHOOD OF OUR NEIGHBORS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES- THERE THERE
MIGHT ROCK STARS AND THEY'RE
AWESOME AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT. SHE
RIGHT THANK YOU. FOR YOUR GONNA
WANT TO. RICHARDSON SECTOR GOV
OFFER. AGENCY AND HEAD OF THE
EASY STRIKE TEAM. GOOD MORE
MISS RICHARDSON.
GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES LET ME
CLEAR. AWESOME GOOD MORNING-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY.
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT THE EDT
STRIKE TEAM APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT NEEDED
IMPROVEMENTS AT THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. IN
ORDER TO SPEED THE PROCESSING
OF CLAIMS- I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
DETERMINED TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES NEEDED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO GET THINGS BACK
ON TRACK. OUR JOB AS THE EDT
STRIKE TEAM IS TO PROVIDE HIM
WITH IMMEDIATE. ACTIONABLE
STEPS THAT CAN BE TAKEN TO HAVE
THE BIGGEST AND MOST
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON SPEEDING
THE PROCESS OF YOU AYE CLAIMS.
WE'RE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS AND
I'M CONFIDENT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO MAKE ROBUST RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE GOVERNOR AND EARLY
SEPTEMBER CONSISTENT WITH HIS
DIRECTION THAT WE REPORT BACK
WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS. THAT
SAID WE ARE NOT WAITING UNTIL
THEN TO ACT AND I WANT TO
ASSURE YOU WE ARE WORKING WITH
DIRECTOR HILLIARD AND HER TEAM
SHE MENTIONED. TO HELP MAKE
IMMEDIATE CHANGES WHEN POSSIBLE.
TODAY I WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT WITH YOU ABOUT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE STRIKE TEAM AND
PROVIDE YOU AN OVERVIEW OF THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN UNDERWAY. I
AM THE CO CHAIR OF THE TEAM
ALONG WITH JENNIFER PARKER. A
CALIFORNIA AND A WELL KNOWN
LEADER IN GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
AND TECHNOLOGY. WORKING WITH
THE OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. WE
HAVE QUICKLY CONVENE A GROUP
WITH KNOWLEDGE OF EDT.
EXPERTISE TO EXAMINE SYSTEMS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND
SKILLS TO IDENTIFY WHERE THE
PROCESSES ARE BREAKING DOWN AND
CAUSES. WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS
PANDEMIC HAS TRIGGERED AN
UNPRECEDENTED VOLUME OF CLAIMS.
AND THAT HAS OVERWHELMED A
SYSTEM THAT RELIES HEAVILY ON
SPECIALIZED HUMAN LABOR. OUR
TEAM IS BRINGING A FRESH SET OF
EYES NOT BURDENED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RUNNING THE
PROGRAM DURING A CRISIS. WE HAD
A PRODUCTIVE THREE WEEKS
MEETING WITH FRONTLINE
EMPLOYEES CLAIMANTS MANAGER'S
LEADERSHIP STAFF AND WITH
LEGISLATORS. WE THE TEAM HAS
VISITED VISITED OFFICES IN
SACRAMENTO AND RANCHO CORDOVA
TO MEET WITH MANAGERS AND TEAMS
FROM DIFFERENT DIVISIONS TO
UNDERSTAND THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. THEY HAVE REVIEW TRAINING
MANUALS AND MATERIALS SHUTTLED
EMPLOYEES WORKING ON CLAIMS AND
FOLLOWING REAL INDIVIDUAL
CLAIMS AS THEY MOVE THROUGH
ED'S MANY DATA SYSTEMS AND
DIVISIONS. THE TEAM VISITED THE
CENTRAL DOCUMENT MANAGEMENT
IDENTITY VERIFICATION AN
OVERPAYMENT UNITSWITH THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTING
INTERVIEWS WITH MANAGERS AND
LEADERSHIP AND FRONTLINE
WORKERS. THE TEAM HAS EVALUATED
THE CLAIMANT EXPERIENCE BY
SPEAKING WITH CLAIMANTS
REVIEWING LEGISLATIVE FEEDBACK
ACCESSING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
CHATBOTS QUERIES REVIEWING
NOTICES REVIEWING CALL CENTER
DATA AND LOOKING AT ELECTRONIC
AND MAIL COMMUNICATIONS SENT BY
CLAIMANTS TO EATING. THE TEAM
HAS MET WITH THE IT SPECIALIST
WHO RUN TEN INDIVIDUAL IT
SYSTEMS WITH ANYBODY UNDERSTAND
HOW EACH OF THEM WORKS AND
WE'RE CHALLENGES LIE. THE TEAM
HAS OBSERVE PHONE SESSIONS WITH
EIGHTY SERVICE CENTER
REPRESENTATIVES AND CLAIMANTS
TO EXPLORE BREAKDOWNS ARE
OCCURRING INCLUDING WHERE
CLAIMS ARE GETTING DERAILED AND
WHY. USING A DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH THE TEAM IS ANALYZING
CLAIMS TECHNICAL SYSTEM AND
WORK USED. TO IDENTIFY PROBLEMS.
AND THE TEAM HAS PUT THEMSELVES
IN THE SHOES OF CLAIMANTS
LOOKING AT MANY OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS THEY RECEIVE AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS ALL
TOO COMMON TO RECEIVE NO
COMMUNICATION AT ALL. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT EIGHTY D. ARE
COMPLEX AND MULTI FACETED. IT
ISN'T AS SIMPLE AS JUST GETTING
NEW SOFTWARE LOADED OR MORE
PEOPLE ANSWERING THE PHONES.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT ISSUES
THAT CAN BE SOLVED INCLUDING
POLICY OP SCHOOL OBSTACLES.
THAT MAKE MANAGING THE PROGRAM
DIFFERENT DIFFICULT AND
INEFFICIENT. WE WILL MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CHANGES IN
LAW AND REGULATION. AS WELL AS
CHANGES TO OPERATION POLICIES
AND PROCESSES TO SPEED THE
PROCESSING OF CLAIMS
IMMEDIATELY. SOME CHANGES ARE
ALREADY BEING IMPLEMENTED AS
YOU HEARD FROM DIRECTOR
HILLIARD SUCH AS BEGINNING
PILOTS ON ELECTRONIC DOCUMENT
UPLOADING AND SORTING AND
RESOLVING CLAIMS BASED ON AGING.
WE ARE WORKING TO HELP EIGHTY
D. ACCELERATE AND OPTIMIZE
THESE EFFORTS SO THAT THERE ARE
NO DELAYS IN MAKING CHANGES
THAT CAN IMPROVE THE CLAIM
EXPERIENCE. DURING THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS. WE WILL WORK WITH EIGHTY
D. TO TEST ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
POSSIBLE DOWNSTREAM EFFECTS OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. SO THAT
WE CAN COME BACK TO THE
GOVERNOR. THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THE ROAD MAP FOR CHANGES THAT
CAN AND WILL MAKE EDT SYSTEMS
BETTER. I KNOW THAT FEEL LIKE
TIME WE CANNOT WASTE I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE UNDERSTAND THE
SENSE OF URGENCY. BUT WENEED
TO ENSURE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WE PUT FORTH HAD THE INTENDED
EFFECTS THAT WE WOULD LIKE THEM
TO HAVE. RIGHT NOW THE TEAM IS
PULLING DATA TO GET A CLEAR
PICTURE. OF THE DATA THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC IN
THE WAYS THAT THEY VIEW IT TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO UNDERSTAND.
BOTH NOW AND IN THE FUTURE. AND
EARLY SEPTEMBER WE WILL MAKE
ADDITIONAL DETAILED
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR LONG TERM
CHANGE TO AVOID PROBLEMS LIKE
THE ONES THAT EDTA IS
EXPERIENCING NOW. AND HAVE BEEN
COMPOUNDED BY THE OLD WAY OF
PROCURING AND IMPLEMENTING
TECHNOLOGY. ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL BE MADE AS
A RESULT OF RIGOROUS ANALYSIS.
DATA DRIVEN APPROACH TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. AND WITH AN EYE
TOWARD HELL WE BUILD SYSTEMS IN
THE FUTURE THAT ARE NIMBLE
ADAPTABLE AND USER FRIENDLY.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY
I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WE
ARE FULLY AWARE. THAT REAL
PEOPLE NEED REAL HELP RIGHT NOW
AND THE STRIKE TEAM IS WORKING
WITH GREAT SPEED. TO HELP TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS GET HELP AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT UP IS BRIAN
WHEELER FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. FOR THOSE
LISTENING IN THE L. A. L. HAND
OUT IS HOSTED ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR WEBPAGE WITH
THE AGENDA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BRIAN YOU ARE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE WANTED OFFERED THREE
SUGGESTIONS TODAY TO THE- TO
THE LEGISLATURE AS YOU CONSIDER
HOW TO GUIDE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND MAKING IMPROVEMENTS. AT
EDT. FIRST WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU ASK THE LEGISLATIVE
ADMINISTRATION A TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE A DOCUMENT THAT
PROVIDES A CLEAR CATALOGING OF
ALL OF THE ACTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN TO DATE TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AT EDT- INCLUDING
WHEN THOSE ACTIONS WERE PUT
INTO PLACE OR WHEN THEY ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE PUT INTO
PLACE- AND HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION. ANTICIPATES
THAT THEY WILL LEAD TO
IMPROVEMENTS AT EDT I WE FOR A
LOT OF GOOD INFORMATION TODAY
ABOUT ACTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN TAKEN I THINK THIS CLEAR A
CLEAR CATALOGUING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HELP- TO
IDENTIFY WHAT'S WORKED AND WHAT
HASN'T TO IDENTIFY WHERE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES MAY BE
NECESSARY OR- WHERE ADDITIONAL
POLICY CHANGES. MAY BE NEEDED
IN AREAS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
FULLY DRESSED YET. ARE SO
SUGGESTION WOULD BE TO FOCUS ON
A LIMITED NUMBER OF KEY ACTIONS
THAT CAN GENERATE- AND
IMMEDIATE IMPACT. US SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES CURRENTLY BEING
FACED- EDT SUCH AS THE
LIMITATIONS OF ITS OUTDATED- I.
T. SYSTEM ARE A LONG STANDING
ISSUES. AND ALL THE STATE WILL
IT WILL EVENTUALLY I NEED TO
MAKE NUMEROUS MEDIUM TO LONG
TERM CHANGES TO BRING ABOUT
IMPROVEMENTS IN EIGHTIES
OPERATIONS- PLACING SO MUCH
FOCUS ON THOSE LONGER TERM
ISSUES RIGHT NOW. A COULD
DIVERT RESOURCES AND EFFORT
AWAY FROM IN ADDRESSING THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS AND SO WE
WOULD SUGGEST AND MOVING
FORWARD IN TALKING ABOUT-
PERHAPS WHICH ACTIONS FROM THE
STRIKE TEAM TO PURSUE. VILLAGES
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD HAVE A
DIALOGUE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE
TRADEOFFS. OF ADDRESSING SOME
OF THESE LONGER TERM ISSUES
VERSUS DEDICATING RESOURCES AND
EFFORT. TO FIXING THE IMMEDIATE
CRISIS FINALLY WE WOULD SUGGEST
IDENTIFYING A FEW KEY
INDICATORS TO TRACK OUR
PROGRESS. AT EDT BASED ON THE
ACTIONS OF A MAN TAKEN TO DATE
AND WHATEVER ACTIONS THE STRIKE
TEAM MAY SUGGEST- WE WORKED
WITH YOUR STAFF I TO IDENTIFY
FIVE KEY INDICATORS- THAT- AND
WE'VE PUT THESE INDICATORS INTO
SOME REPORTING TRAILER BILL-
THAT WOULD ASK EDT TO PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS EVERY TWO
WEEKS- TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO THE PUBLIC ON THEIR WEBSITE.
I AND WE THINK THAT THESE
METRICS SHOULD GIVE A SHOULD
BE. SHOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO DRAW CLEAR
PICTURE ABOUT PROGRESS THAT'S
BEING MADE AND CLEARING UP.
SOME OF THE BACKLOG EDT IN
IMPROVING TIME AND IN CLAIM
PROCESS. A WE WERE KNOW THOUGH
THAT WE THINK THESE AND ARE THE
BEST ONES IN THE CLEAREST ONE
TO BE TRACKING FOR THE SHORT
TERM FOR THE GAME. THE
IMPROVEMENT IN THE IMMEDIATE
CRISIS. AS THE- CRISIS STARTS
TO ABATE THOUGH YOU MIGHT WANT
TO REEVALUATE THESE INDICATORS
AND START PLACING MORE WEIGHT
ON SOME OF THE MORE TRADITIONAL
TIMELESSNESS METRICS- SUCH AS
THE ONES THAT THE DIRECTOR I
TALKED ABOUT. EARLIER WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF TO EVALUATE THIS
DATA AS IT COMES IN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND HELP YOU TO.
GAUGE WHETHER IT IS SHOWING
THAT PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AT
EDT. HAVE ANY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS THANK YOU AND INALLY
WE HAVE MORE COMMITMENTS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. OF FINANCE MR
MENACE. I AM ARGUMENT A
PERMANENT I'M NOT BEING. AS BUT
I AM AVAILABLE ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR COMMENTS I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO
START WITH THE MOVE ON THE
OTHER MEMBERS TO THEIR
QUESTIONS. AND. THE FIRST
QUESTION FOR MISS HILLIARD. YES.
WHAT IS THE CURRENT WAIT TIME
FOR A CALL BACK FROM EIGHTY D.
CURRENTLY- WE'RE ABOUT THIRTEEN
THOUSAND IN THE QUEUE AND WE'RE
WORKING WE'RE ON AUGUST
TWENTIETH RIGHT NOW. OKAY. SO
WE CAN DO IS ONE OF TWO WAYS
THE MEMBERS WE CAN. EVERYONE
ACCIDENT DISLOCATION YOU CAN
JUST QUEUE UP AND- TELL ME WANT
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF SO IT'S A
QUESTION FROM A FULL YEAR. YES
GOVERNOR. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
OKAY HI TO HILLIARD THANK FOR
PROVIDE US WITH STATE AND
GIVING GIVE US THIS CONTENT TO
DIG INTO JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IF YOU WERE GOING
THROUGH THIS PRESENTATION AT
FIRST ON THE AT THE STAFF
LEVELS SO I BELIEVE YOU SAID
THAT THE GOAL IS TO GROW THE
TEAM AND THEY'LL HAVE NINETEEN
HUNDRED CALL CENTER REPS WHO
WILL PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED. WHAT I WOULD CALL CASE
WORKERS WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL
LEVEL TWO OR SOMETHING ELSE DID
I UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY
OKAY- YES OKAY BUT WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO YOU CALL THOSE PEOPLE
CASE WORKERS LEVEL TWO WHAT
SHOULD WE- THERE ARE POINT. PRO
REPRESENTATIVES THAT. THE IN
NATIONAL STAFF TO HELP ON THE
CALL. SPECIFIC USE GOT IT OKAY
SO I. OUR COMPLAINT PROGRAM ARE
PRESENTED AS I'D LOOK WHEN WE
LAST SPOKE AT THE END OF JULY
THERE WERE A HUNDRED OF THOSE
FOLKS THAT WERE. ON THE PHONES.
YOUR GOAL IS TO GROW UP TO
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED WHERE ARE WE
RIGHT NOW. IF YOU LOOK ON THE
CHART YEAH- BY THE END OF-
AUGUST- WE'LL TO TALK. AND YOUR
CARD IT IS SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE I
WAS JUST TRYING TO ADD THAT
SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE IS WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE ON
THE CHART I'M GLAD THAT IS A
LITTLE. ON THE CHART I'M
LOOKING AT IT'S ALL BLANK SO IT
IT HAS YOU AYE CLAIM SUPPORT.
APRIL TO JUNE YOU I STAFF LEVEL
A HUNDRED AND THENEVERYTHING
ELSE ALL THE OTHER BOXES ARE.
PERFECT BLANK OCTOBER TRANSFER
RIGHT CENTERS LAST MINUTE RIGHT
WHAT I'M TRYING. YEAH WHAT I'M
TRYING TO PORTRAY IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE COMBINING
BOTH OF THOSE CALL CENTERS.
CALL LINES INTO ONE IN OCTOBER
SO THEY'LL ALL BE TOGETHER AND
AS SUCH WITH THE SKILL BASED
ROUTING AND IT- ADDITION OF ALL
THE PROFESSIONAL STAFF. WHAT
WE'RE GONNA END UP WITH IS THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED- EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WRAPS IT CAN REALLY DIG
INTO THOSE MORE COMPLEX CLAIMS.
GREAT I THINK YOU YEAH AND SO I
ST WITH SORRY WHERE WE TODAY SO
WE HAD A HUNDRED ON JULY THIRTY
FIRST AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED BUT HOW MANY DO WE HAVE
TODAY RIGHT YEAH LET ME LET ME
JUST CONFIRM WITH. MICHELLE SHE
OF THE NUMBERS. IN A LOT OF.
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE IT RIGHT BY
OUR BUT I WAS THIS TO YOU FALL
THE HEARING OKAY THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AND THAT WAS A MAJOR
AREA OF FOCUS ON THAT IN OUR
LAB SELECTION OKAY AND THEN
YEAH PAGE THREE CALL CENTER. SO
RIGHT NOW WE'RE OFFERING 40% OF
CALLS SO WHAT HAPPENS. TO THESE
OTHER CALLS. THEY JUST PEOPLE
HANG UP THERE'S GIVE U. OR ARE
THEY CALL BACK LATER AND I KEEP
TRYING OR THEY EMAIL I MEAN.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THAT'S WHY WE
WANT TO KEEP IMPROVING EVERY
ABILITY TO RESPOND BECAUSE
ANYBODY NOT SERVED IS IT'S NOT
A GOOD SITUATION. SO THAT'S WHY
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO ADD
RESOURCES AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GO WAY BEYOND WHERE WE WERE PRE
PANDEMIC AND REALLY BE CUT HAVE
A CALL CENTER THAT WORK. WE'RE
PROUD OF- AND THAT WE'RE
SERVING RATE BODY SELF YEAH
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A GOOD
SITUATION- WE'RE DEFINITELY
DOING BETTER MUCH BETTER THAN
WE WERE- BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WE KNOW- WE WANT TO GET TO A
PLACE. WHERE WE'RE PROUD OF IT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING.
BUT ON THE CALL CENTER IN IN
FEBRUARY BEFORE PAY DEPEND KIT
WE'RE ONLY FIFTY FOUR PER IF
YOU MISSED TO YEAH MR STERN IS
A WHY EVERYBODY PERCENT SO
WASN'T IT A PER PREPEND BECAUSE
WHENEVER YES WE NEVER HAVE- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT FUN
FOR CALL CENTER ACTIVITIES-
THEY DON'T AND SO WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE FUNDING IN ORDER TO
FOR SUPPORT ANYBODY ABOUT ME ON
THAT IN ORDER TO BE AWARE THAT
FOCUS OUR RESOURCES ON PAYING
PEOPLE. BUT WITH THE WITH THE
PANDEMIC DID SOME- SOME
TEMPORARY OF FUNDING- YOU KNOW
SO I'M USING THE FUNDING TO
REALLY ELEVATE OUR CENTER NOW
AFTER THE PANDEMIC WHEN IT GETS
BACK INTO NORMAL TIMES I'M
CONCERNED BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IT'LL GO BACK TO THE SITUATION
AS WELL WE HAVE FUNDING TO
REALLY- SUPPORT OR CALL CENTER
SO THAT IS SOMETHING- IN THE
NEXT YEAR TOO I THINK WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT AS FAR AS WHAT
WHAT DO WE WANT EDT TO LOOK
LIKE MOVING FORWARD. BECAUSE
BUT IN THE PAST OBVIOUSLY SO
SOUNDS LIKE THIS BEFORE. HAS
BEEN THE NORM FIFTY. SO I GUESS
MIKE I ASKED IN THE PAST. IS
THE LEADERSHIP EVER PUT A FOR
BC. TO GET PERSONNEL. AND WE DO
WE DO RECEIVE. STATE FUNDING
FOR IT. BUT BUT BEFORE THAT AND
SO I MISS THAT YOU SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THE CALL CENTER. FOR
ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES GOT TO
LOWER THAT NUMBER SO. I WOULD
SAY I WOULD GUESS IF YOU PUT IN
FOR IT- YOU'VE BEEN TURNED DOWN
FOR WHEN YOU'VE APPLIED FOR IT
IS THAT CORRECT. UP WELL
PARTIALLY I MEAN WE DO HAVE
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE STATE
THAT SUPPLEMENT IN ORDER FOR US
TO- ANSWER CALLS BECAUSE- PRIOR
TO THAT WE WERE ANSWERING AT A
MUCH LOWER LEVEL UNTIL THE LAST
FEW YEARS WHEN THE STATE
STEPPED IN TO HELP SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM THAT IS. TERRIBLY
UNDERFUNDED AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. SO YOU CAN GET A LITTLE
LOWER THAN 54% I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY THEY CAN
UNFORTUNATELY KNOW IT'S
TERRIBLE. I KEEP. YEAH ABSOLUTE
COURSE YOU CAN FIND ON ABOUT.
AT GOOD ACTUALLY DIED AT I
THINK FOR ALL OF US. I THINK
WE'RE ALL REALLY SURPRISE TO
SEE THAT NUMBER BE. PREPEND
THEM OUT WE WERE EXPERIENCING
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE
STATE. SO YEAH THAT THAT RAISES
AT REACTIVE BIG RED FLAG FOR ME
AS WELL. RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT TIMES RECORD LOW
STAFFING LEVELS BECAUSE OUR
FUNDING DECREASES IN LINE WITH
THAT- THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. SO
YOU KNOW. THAT THE FUNDING THAT
WE GET GOES DOWN TO SO WE CAN
ONLY STAFF WHAT WE HAVE FUNDING
FOR. AND IT'S SHAMEFUL IT'S
SHAMEFUL NATIONALLY I'M NOT OF
THE STATE'S ARE IN GOOD SHAPE
WHEN IT COMES TO. ANSWERING
CALLS AND IT'S JUST SHAMEFUL
FOR A NATION OF OUR OUR- GREAT
LEVEL. OKAY YES I WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT THIS IS. AND I OKAY
SO. MOVING TO SLIDE FOR. THE
FIVE. BUT UNPAID CLAIMS. SO WE
STILL HAVE ONE MILLION UNPAID
CLAIMS. IS THAT CORRECT. UNPAID
YEAH YES OKAY AND- WHAT IS WHEN
ARE THEY GOING TO BE CLEARED
YOU SAID IT'S A PORTION OF THEM
ARE GOING TO BE CLEARED BY THE
END OF SEPTEMBER. CAN YOU JUST
BREAK THAT DOWN. OF THE TO. THE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND IS- THE ONES THAT WILL
BE CLEARED BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER THAT WE- COMMITTED
TO. AND THE OTHER BUCKETS- LIKE
I SAID WE'VE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS TO- BECAUSE PEOPLE
HAVE GONE IN AND CERTIFIED- AS
YOU WILL SEE THE PAID AMOUNT
WENT UP. A 2% TO AND THAT'S
BECAUSE- PEOPLE ARE GOING IN
AND CERTIFYING AND- FOR
BENEFITS AND THEN THEY'RE
GETTING. PAID OR THEIR- IF
THERE'S ANY ISSUES AND WORK
THEIR WORK WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM SO. THE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM AS IS. EVERY DAY'S A
DIFFERENT DAY I'M MOVING. YOU
KNOW THEY'RE MOVING FROM.
INITIAL CLAIMS TO CONTINUE
CLAIMS TO. DIFFERENT PLACES IN
THE PROCESS SO. WE SEEM GREAT
MOVEMENT IN THIS LAST FOUR
WEEKS. A I THINK ONE THING I
WOULD FIND INCREDIBLY HELPFUL
AND I IMAGINE SO MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD AS WELL IS. IF WE COULD
JUST GET SOME ADDITIONAL
VISIBILITY INTO THAT THE
BALANCE THAT'S ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND. TO
UNDERSTAND YEAH- YOU KNOW. WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THOSE BECAUSE FROM
RIGHT ACCURATE SAYING WE'VE
WE'VE GOT ADDED RESOLUTION IN
SIGHT FOR TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE. BUT WE REALLY DON'T. HAVE
A PLAN FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND SO IF WE CAN GET
SOME ADDITIONAL VISIBILITY IN
ADDITIONAL DETAIL TO WHAT THE
HURDLES ARE THAT WOULD BE.
INCREDIBLY YEAH VALUABLE. I'M
WE DO HAVE A PLAN PEOPLE ARE
MOVING AND BEING PAID AND- THEY
DISLOCATIONS THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
SEEING THE 47% REDUCTION- OF-
AND PEOPLE MOVING TO EITHER
PAID OR ON ELIGIBLE OR WHEREVER
THEY LAND. BUT ON ALL THE
VISIBILITY FOR DATA WE STARTED
WORKING WITH THE STRIKE TEAM
LAST WEEK TO REDEFINE ALL OF
OUR BUCKETS AND MAKING SURE.
THAT WE'RE APPROACHING
REPORTING FROM A CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE- APPROACH. SO AT I
THINK IN THE FUTURE AFTER WE
WORK THROUGH THE DETAILS AS-
SECRETARY RICHARDSON SAID. I'M
TRYING SOME THINGS AND THEN BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE GOOD GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS I'M EXCITED TO
SEE HOW WE SORT OF RECAST. OUR
REPORTING SO- YOU KNOW IT MAKES
SENSE TO AND DIGESTIBLE FOR THE
OUTSIDE WORLD. YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING ADMITTEDLY WITH
REPORTING BECAUSE OF OUR OLD
ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS. SO I'M
EAGER TO YOU KNOW WE'VE ALREADY
HAD SOME GOOD CONVERSATION AND
A FRESH LOOK AT HOW. HOW TO
REPORT SO THERE'LL BE A LOT
MORE COMING YOUR WAY AS FAR
THAT AS FAR AS THAT GOES I'M
SURE. GONNA WANT YOUR INPUT ON
ON WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. OKAY GREAT
AND BEFORE I BEFORE BEFORE I
HANDED OVER I DO WANT TO TOUCH
ON YOU MENTIONED. THAT YOU'RE
ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS AND- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY. IN THE LAST
HEARING AND I YOU CAN PRE.
BRIEFING THE SENSE I'VE GOTTEN
THE- IS. SORT OF THE SENSE ET
TECHNO IS TO THIS INTO. PROBLEM
AND WE'VE GOT THE SORT OF IN.
HURDLES LIKE LEGACY SYSTEMS AND
HER AND- COBALT. I WAS. THE
FOLLOWING LAST YEAR I AND I
NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES AND
PERHAPS EVEN OTHERS ON THAT ARE
ON THE PANEL. I WAS CONTACTED
BY A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES WHO.
AREN'T CAN NAME BRAND PROVEN
ENTITIES WHO HAVE IMPLEMENTED
SOLUTIONS AND OTHER STATES WHO
HAVE SAID THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE SOLUTIONS THAT
CAN HELP CALIFORNIA AND A
MATTER OF. WEEKS NOT MONTHS
AND- TO HAVE OU BEEN CONTACTED
BY THESE COMPANIES AS WELL
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION. AND BEEN
TALKING TO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT VENDORS AND NUMBER
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS JUST LIKE
DOCUSIGN THERE'S ONE RIGHT
THERE. THAT WE'RE BRINGING IN-
SO WE WOULD HAVE NEVER
DIFFERENT VENDORS ARE USING TO
HELP- HELP WITH ALL OF THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND LIKE. A
SECRETARY RICHARDSON SAID I'M I
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO COME UP
WITH SOME MORE GREAT. THOUGHT
SO- I THINK YEAH I THINK YOU'LL
BE SEEING MORE OF IT THAT MOST
DEFINITELY. YOU HAVE THE I WAS
SURPRISED SO THE FEEDBACK THAT
THAT I. WAS THAT MULTIPLE
ATTEMPTS TO REACH OUT TO YOU
AND TO YOUR DEPARTMENT. WERE
JUST IGNORED- AND YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT LIKE IT'S MY BROTHER'S
START UP TECHNOLOGY THING IT
WAS YOU KNOW THE NAME BRAND
COMPANIES. SO I'M SURPRISED TO
HEAR THAT AND- WOULD HOPE THAT
WE- BRINGING. YOU KNOW EVERYONE
TOGETHER TO. COME UP WITH
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON THIS AT. ABSOLUTELY
AND YEAH YOU KNOW PLEASE KNOW
THAT WE'RE GETTING- CONTACTED
BY THOUSANDS OF DIFFERENT
VENDORS- WANTING TO ASK TO
REVIEW- WHAT THEY'VE GOT GOING
ON AND HOW THEY CAN HELP. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE PARTNERING
WITH CD T. AN ODI TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE ALL THAT AND- GREAT
TECHNOLOGISTS LOOKING AT IT.
AND THAT WERE REALLY- WAITING
THROUGH ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT MAKES SENSE
FOR EDT. SO AGAIN I VALUE THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND IT'S REALLY
BEEN. HELPFUL TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE MOVING EIGHTY IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. GREAT AND THEN
JUST LASTLY I. THOUGHT THAT THE
ALEJO'S DESERVED THREE VERY
SIMPLE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
SPOT ON. IT ARE YOU SUPPORTIVE
OF THOSE. YES I HAVE NO
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT SOUND GOOD-
WE CAN EASILY CATALOG WE
ACTUALLY WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
PRETTY MUCH KELLOGG BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT- THE METRICS ARE
TALKED ABOUT WAS FINE AND-
CERTAINLY THE SHORT TERM- THING
WINDS THAT CAN BE DONE- I THINK
THAT WILL COME OUT IS WORKING
WITH THE STRIKE TEAM WE'VE
ALREADY DONE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT. WOULD HELP SHORT TERM
THAT YOU KNOW LOW IMPACT OR
HIGH IMPACT WITH LOW EFFORT- SO
I WELCOME ADDITIONAL IDEAS SO.
AGAIN THAT'S A AND WORKING WITH
THE STRIKE TEAM I THINK MORE OF
THAT'S GOING TO COME OUT SO I
THINK IT'S TERRIFIC. GREAT
THANK YOU AND WHAT ABOUT THE
OTHER L. L.'S OTHER TO. ARE YOU
OKAY WITH THOSE. WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT I CAN. FOR THREE ON THE
RECORDING WAS GOOD THAT WAS.
AND TRADITIONAL MEASURE YEP
THAT'S GOOD TO YEAH NO I WAS
FINE WITH ALL OF THEM SURE IT
IS MORE PUSHED ON THE CLAIMS
THE CLAIM THAT AS ALWAYS PEOPLE
ARE ENTERING ON THEIR OWN AND
EVEN IF YOU'RE ONLINE AND NOT
IT'S NOT EASY. I'VE BEEN IN MY
WRONG PHONE NUMBER MY WRONG
EMAIL BEFORE- ON SOCIAL ARE YOU
GUYS TO GO TO THIS WE TALKED TO
I KNOW I TALKED THE STARTING
ABOUT THIS. ARE YOU GUYS GOING
TO GO TO THIS FORMER AT LEAST
TWICE TO MAKE SURE IT'S THE
CORRECT INFORMATION BEING
ENTERED BECAUSE THAT AMOUNT OF
THE IMPRESSION ALL THESE CLAIMS
BECAUSE SOMETIMES INFORMATION.
GETS INJURED IN AN PEOPLE
TRANSPOSE THE NUMBER. YEAH WE
HAVE PROBLEM WITH THE SO.
NUMBERS PARTICULARLY- AND WE
HAVE SINCE FIXED THAT AND WE DO
HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE WORK-
YOU DO ENTER AT NUMBER OF TIMES
I THINK THREE THREE TIMES.
AGAINST SO THAT ROLLED OUT. I
YEAH AWESOME SO IT'S EASY TO
CREATE. BUT I WILL SAY WITH
SOME EACH OFFICE BEING SLOW TO.
A EASY RAP. STAFFERS TOLD ME
MUCH BECAUSE- THEY'VE CLEARLY
QUITE A FEW CLAIMS WORKING WITH
ONE PERSON THEY'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH THAT SO. YOU GUYS
HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB ON THAT SO.
AND I. THANK ALL YOUR ALL YOUR
STAFF. BECAUSE WE AS YOU KNOW
WE NEED A THEM EVERY TWO WEEKS
AND ALLOW. REFERRAL PER. WEEK
TO REFINE. UP BASED ON THEIR
INPUT IN WHAT IF IS WORKING AND
AT OUR LAST MEETING WE DID HEAR
SOME REALLY GOOD FEEDBACK THAT-
HAVING PEOPLE ASSIGNED TO THE
VARIOUS OFFICES IS REALLY HELP
CLEAR OUT SOME OF THOSE
SPECIALLY THOSE ONES ARE LESS
COMPLICATED. SO THANK YOU. MR
TRUE. THANK YOU LET. THANK YOU
ME JUST START WITH A OF. QUICK
CALL. I KNOW WE'VE HAD AN ANTI
COME ABOUT EDT AND- MANY OF US
ABOUT CRITIQUES AROUND HOW EDS
BEEN FAILING BUT I WANT TO
START. AS OUR CHAIRMAN STARTED
BY JUST THINKING OF PARTICULAR
THE RANK AND FILE OF EDP WHO I
KNOW ARE WORKING INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT SITUATION SO IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK FOR US TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM- I ALSO WANT
TO. REITERATE SOMETHING THAT I
THINK YOU KNOW WHICH IS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS MONTH SEVENTY
ONE MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
INCLUDING MOST OF THE MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMITTEE SENT THE
GOVERNOR A LETTER OUTLINING AT
LEAST SIX AREAS IN WHICH WE ARE
LOOKING FOR EASY REFORM. AND ON
A POSITIVE NOTE I WANTED TO SAY
HOW GRATEFUL I AM THAT THERE'S
BEEN REAL MOVEMENT ON THE FIRST
MAJOR RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
DISTRICT TEAM- I KNOW THEY ARE
WORKING HARD TO DIVE INTO WHAT
NEEDS CHANGE. I HAVE A LOT OF
FAITH IN THEIR LEADERSHIP SO
LOOKING LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
MIDDLE SEPTEMBER WHEN WE'RE
GONNA GET THEIR INITIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT I DO WANT
TO SAY IS WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED
FEEDBACK ON PROBABLY ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE LETTER I KNOW
DIRECTOR HILLIARD YOU AND I'VE
NOT. HAD A CHANCE TO MEET YET
ABOUT IT BUT- I WANT TO TOUCH
ON SOME OF THOSE AREAS IN THE
DISCUSSION AND LET ME JUST JUMP
TO WHAT TO OUR RECOGNITION AND
CLEARING THE BACKLOG AND SOME
OF THE DATA THAT YOU PROVIDED
THIS MORNING. IF I COULD JUST
JUMP TO PAGE FIVE OF THE. DATA
THAT YOU PRESENTED THIS MORNING.
SO OF THE NUMBERS ARE. THE
RELEASE OUT AT ME. THE GOOD. OF
THE EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY TH.
CLAY AS OF LAST MONTH. THAT MAY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION WHICH DROPPED TO
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN.
THOUSAND THAT'S GOOD NEWS. THE
PENDING EDT RESOLUTION NUMBER
TWO THIRTY NINE DROPPING EIGHTY
TWO THOUSAND. THAT'S GOOD NEWS
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS. IF WE
RESOLVED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN THE FIRST CATEGORY
AND A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND THE SECOND CATEGORY.
IT'S ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOLKS IT SEEMS LIKE YOU PROCESS
THE LAST MONTH. I WOULD HAVE
EXPECTED. THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
PAID. FOR THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO WERE DECLARED INELIGIBLE TO
REFLECT. THE PROCESSING. WHERE
THOSE NUMBERS GO. DID YOU
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE ALL IN YES I
DO THEY WENT INTO THE PAID THEY
WENT INTO THE INELIGIBLE. THEY
WENT INTO PENDING- THAT'S AT
THE VERY BOTTOM YOU SEE.
RESOLUTION DO SO THAT'S EXACTLY
MY QUESTION SO THE PAID NUMBER
CANNOT GO UP ONE FROM FOUR
POINT EIGHT TO FOUR POINT NINE.
THE INELIGIBLE WENT UP BY 1%
ONE SIXTY TWO TO ONE SIXTY
FOURTH. BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE SO
JUST I DON'T SEE HOW THAT MATH
COMPUTES. DOES THAT BECAUSE I
CAN. YES IT IS DISCUSSING AND
IT IS DISPERSED THROUGH THE
VARIOUS BUCKETS- IF YOU WANT TO
COMPLETE RECONCILIATION WE
CERTAINLY CAN TAKE THAT BACK IN
SENATE TO AFTER THE HEARING BUT
CAN YOU GIVE ME A SENSE OF IF
YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU PROCESS
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CLAIMANTS DID MOST OF THOSE
FOLKS GET PAID. FOR MOST OF
THOSE FOLKS DECLARED INELIGIBLE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM. WHAT
SOME OF THEM GOT PAID SOME OF
THEM GOT UP FOUND AN ELIGIBLE
AS A DATE IT REFLECTS AND- IS
KNOWN TO THE PENDING
RESOLUTION. I'M SORRY THE DATE
IS ON FRONT OF US. RIGHT. SO
THE CHART ON EIGHT TWENTY. SOME
AT PLUS TWO FIRST 42% INCREASE
IN A MORE PEOPLE GOT PAID- OF
SOME PEOPLE- FEWER PEOPLE WERE
ARE MORE PEOPLE WERE FOUND IN
ELIGIBLE. THAT WENT UP AND THEN.
MORE CASES CAME- TO EDT THAT
NEED TO BE RESOLVED AND BE
TOUCHED BY IT AT INDIVIDUAL.
SUFFRAGISTS RESTATE THE
QUESTION I'M SORRY I'M JUST I'M
JUST BAFFLED BY THESE NUMBERS
AGAIN SO YOU SAY THAT. THERE
WERE SIX ABOUT CLOSE TO SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOLKS THAT YOU
MANAGE A PROCESS IN THE LAST
MONTH AND THAT'S GREAT. WHAT
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS WHY
DID THE UNPAID NUMBER ONLY GO
UP BY A HUNDRED THOUSAND. AND
THE INELIGIBLE NUMBER ONLY GO
UP BY. LOOKS LIKE TWO THOUSAND.
SO WHAT HAPPENED TO A HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE WHERE THEY
REFLECTED IN THIS. THE NUMBERS
SO I LIKE IT. I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING YEAH. DANJEL. YEAH WE'LL
HAVE TO COME BACK AND- PROVIDE
AN ACCOUNTING FOR IT BECAUSE-
IT IS DISBURSED FOR ALL THE
BUCKETS AND. WE'LL GET BACK TO
ARE NOT APPRECIATE THEIR
DISPERSED REGISTRADA OBVIOUSLY
FIGURE OUT WHETHER DISPERSED.
GOING BACK TO. FOUR WHERE YOU
TALK ABOUT THE FACT AS AT THE
END OF JULY 75% LIMITED RECEIVE
THEIR FIRST PAYMENT. APPRECIATE
THAT NUMBER ONE OF THE
COMPLAINTS WE GET FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS THEY GET A
FIRST PAYMENT. AND THEY DON'T
HEAR FROM YOU TODAY FOR WEEKS
IF NOT MONTHS. DO YOU HAVE ANY
METRIC TO GET US A SENSE OF HOW
MANY CLAIMANTS. TOTAL HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THE PAYMENTS AT THE
THINK OR DO THEY ARE DO. NOT AT
THIS TIME BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE DISCUSSING WITH THE
STRAIGHT TEAM- LIKE I SAID WE
WANT TO COME BACK AND WRITE
HOLISTIC INFORMATION THAT IS
THAT REALLY LAYS OUT THE
EXPERIENCE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE IN THE JOURNEY. SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS WERE IN
DEEP DISCUSSION WITH THE STRIKE
TEAM ABOUT. GREAT HI I'LL JUST
REITERATE FOR THE STRIKE TEAM
THAT'S A VERY COMMON COMPLAINT
WE HAVE FROM CONSTITUENTS A
MASSIVE TO CHECK IN MARCH. OR
APRIL RIGHT THEN THERE'S SORT
OF RADIO SILENCE AND THEY'VE NO
IDEA WHAT'S HAPPENED. I'M GOING
TO PAGE THREE OF THE CALL
CENTER. AROUND CALL CENTER DATA
I THINK ONE. METRIC THAT WOULD
BE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
IS JUST. THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
CALLS IT'S ONE THING. TO KNOW
HOW MANY CALLS ARE ANSWERING.
BUT TO KNOW HOW MANY CALLS ARE
COMING IN. HOW MANY CALLS
INVOLVE REPEAT DIALING THAT'S
THE INCREDIBLE FRUSTRATION THAT
FOLKS ARE HAVING AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT RIGHT IN
THIS CHART BUT I DID- I DID-
GIVE YOU VERBALLY A LAST MOST
RECENTLY WAS FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION CALLS WE RECEIVE IN A
WEEK WE CERTAINLY CAPTURE THAT
DATA AND IF THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO SEE WILL BE GLAD TO
PROVIDE IT- THE CALLS HAVE COME
DOWN. AND GREATLY. AND THAT'S
WE'RE UP FOURTEEN. MILLION A
WEEK AND NOW WE'RE DOWN TO FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION A WEEK WHICH
IS STILL. A HUGE HUGE. BUT I'M
DEFINITELY GOING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND ONE THING I'LL
SAY ABOUT THAT IS WE ARE
HEARING FROM CONSTITUENTS WHO.
SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN EARLIER
MONTHS CALLING INTO THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T GET
THROUGH THEY LITERALLY JUST
GIVEN UP. SO YEAH ON THE ONE
HAND IT'S GREAT THAT THE
NUMBERS GOING DOWN IT COULD BE
GOING DOWN FOR VARIETY REASONS
AND I WANT TO JUST MENTION
THAT. YEAH YEAH. SO RELATED TO
THIS AT THE LAST HEARING YOU
SUGGESTED THAT. THAT EDT WAS
WORKING ON A DASHBOARD-
METRICS. UNDERSTAND WHERE
THINGS ARE. AND AGAIN PROBABLY
WHERE THAT- A NUMBER OF US
INCLUDING- THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS
STAFF. THE CHAIR OF OUR
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
OF MY OFFICE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE TO
UNDERSTAND. SORT OF METRICS
EVERY TWO WEEKS WOULD BE. WOULD
GRATEFUL. ON WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM YOU IS THAT YOU'RE VERY
WILLING TO COME TO WORK WITH US
ON THAT. DO YOU GUYS HAVE A
DASHBOARD UP AND- UP I THINK
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST IS FOR
THE- FOR THE STRIKE FORCE. TO
HELP PROPOSED FOR US THE RIGHT
METRICS FOR US TO FOCUS ON
BECAUSE A LOT OF NUMBERS YOU
CAN FOCUS ON. AND ON. WE DON'T
WANT TO BE I THINK OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE AND WHAT WE ASK
YOU TO DO BUT I THINK. THERE
ARE KEY DATA. THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS THE ORGANIZATION ON THE
PUBLIC ON ON OUR MAKING
PROGRESS ON THIS SO. WANT TO
JUST GET A SENSE OF RIGHT NOW
ABSOLUTELY. NOT WE CAME UP WITH
A DRY. OUT BOARD BUT WE PURPOSE
DIDN'T PUT OUT BECAUSE WHEN
INDUSTRY TEAM WAS. IN AND WE
WANTED TO OFFER. TO HAVE FRESH
EYES BEEN TO CLOSE IT YOU KNOW
AND WE NEED TO SET UP. ICE TAKE
A LOOK AT IT. YEAH RECORD WHAT
WOULD REALLY WORK IN IT I
THOUGHT THE DASHBOARDS ALL TIED
TO THE WHOLE. DATA REPORTING
AND INVENTORIES AND ALL OF THAT
SO LIKE I SAID WE STARTED
WORKING LAST. WEEK WITH THE
STRIKE TEAM. AND IF NOTHING
GETS RIGHT. I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PART TO REALLY- PUT
SOME GOOD BRAINS BEHIND THIS
AND- FINALLY GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN PROVIDE DATA
THAT'S MEANINGFUL. FOR US IN
MEANINGFUL FOR THE OUTSIDE
WORLD WE ALL DESERVE THAT. IT'S
BEEN A STRUGGLE I'M NOT I'M NOT
HIDDEN THAT FROM DAY ONE- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR ANTIQUATED
SYSTEMS. PROVIDE DATA BASED ON.
WHEN WORK GOES INTO A QUEUE
IT'S NOT BASED ON THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE LIKE IT NEEDS TO BE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE STRIKE TEAM TO HELP
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
TRANSLATE. INFORMATION THAT WE
DO HAVE IN OUR ANTIQUATED
SYSTEMS. INTO SOMETHING THAT IT
PAINTS A PICTURE. HOLISTICALLY
FOR THE CUSTOMER YOU REFERENCE
THE CHALLENGES AROUND
TECHNOLOGY AND I WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON THE COMMENTS OF- OF OUR
COLLEAGUE- MISCARRIAGE NORRIS
OVER JUST TECHNOLOGY AND THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY A MAJOR SUBJECT OF
OUR LETTER. OUR LETTER
REFERENCED A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT EDIE'S. CHALLENGING
HISTORY OF ENGAGING WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO MODERNIZE ITS
SYSTEMS. PARTICULARLY AS YOUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN PARTNERING
WITH DELIGHT. WHICH AS YOU KNOW
IS RECEIVED OVER A QUARTER
BILLION DOLLARS. IN RECENT
YEARS TO WORK ON IT SYSTEM- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LIGHTS
PERFORMANCE AND I WANT TO ASK
YOU. YOU KNOW THE LAST HEARING.
I ASK YOU A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
EDT AND LAW. FOR AND WAS FOR.
TO ME. THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE VARIOUS. YES OR NO
ANSWERS AND BY THE WAY THE
ANSWERS YOU PROVIDED. FOR THE
ONES THAT I THOUGHT WERE THE
CORRECT ANSWERS. BUT WHEN OUR
STAFF POSE THOSE SAME QUESTIONS
TO DELOITTE. WE WERE SEE VERY
CONTRADICTORY OR EVASIVE
RESPONSES. TO THE SAME
QUESTIONS AS I MENTIONED TO YOU.
I'M CURIOUS SINCE THE LAST
HEARING. WHAT HAS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE LIGHT THAT.
NOTHING'S CHANGED- I DID REACH
OUT TO THE LATE AFTER THE
HEARING TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT-
AND THERE IS A- COMMUNICATION
ISSUE BECAUSE- THERE TOLD ME
THAT WHAT I SAID WAS SPOT ON
WITH THEM THERE ANDERSON THEIR
FEELING OF THE RELATIONSHIP TO.
ONE THING I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
DELOITTE- I UNDERSTAND YOUR
FRUSTRATION WITH THEM THEY YOU
KNOW THROUGHOUT THE YEARS IT'S
A YOU KNOW ALWAYS A COMPETITIVE
BID PROCESS THAT WE FOLLOW THAT
IS- DETERMINED BY THE STATE AND
MONITOR BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. I
DON'T I DON'T YOU KNOW SELECT
PEOPLE OR VENDORS IT ALL GOES
THROUGH A VERY RIGOROUS
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS THAT'S
STRUCTURED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT SO I MEAN
IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
OVERALL PROCUREMENT OF. YOU
KNOW FOR STATE AGENCIES- REALLY
I THINK YOU NEED T READ DIRECT
US TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
PROCESSES. AND THE STATE RULES
AND REGULATIONS SO. YOU KNOW
THE THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS IN
AS A DIRECTOR AT IT'S MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT I'M FOLLOWING THE
DIRECTION OF THE MINISTRATION
AND HOPING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND DOING WHAT NEEDS TO GET
DONE BUT I DON'T MAKE THOSE
RULES I BUT I MAKE SURE WE
FOLLOW THEM APPROPRIATELY AND-
FOLLOW ALL THE STEPS AS
REQUIRED SO. THANKS I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU REFER TO
THE COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS BUT
ISN'T IT TRUE. THAT THIS YEAR.
YOU ACCEPTED TO NO BID
CONTRACTS WITH THE LAWYER
DURING THIS PANDEMIC TO WORK
ON. THE SYSTEM. YES DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC AND UP THE BILL USE
EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT- THEY
WERE THE VENDORS THAT- I'VE
CREATED YOU I ON LINE. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE NEEDED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN ORDER TO
TURNER- BRING ON THE- PANDEMIC
IN EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND OTHER PROGRAMS. SO
WE NEEDED THEIR SUPPORT
EMERGENCY SITUATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY ABSOLUTELY AGREED
THEY WERE ON A LIST THAT HAD TO
BE COMPLETE YEP- COMPETITIVELY-
PUT ON SO- AT YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE TO QUALIFY FOR AT THE LIST
IN ORDER TO BE CHOSEN. AND WE
DID THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE TO WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO BRING UP NEW
VENDORS TO FIGURE OUT OUR
SYSTEM THAT THEY BUILT- WE NEED
TO DO TO ROLL SOMETHING OUT YOU
KNOW AS- AS POSSIBLE. AND WE
NEED WE PULLED IN ANY AND ALL
VENDORS THAT WOULD HELP WITH
THAT. BECAUSE WE'RE ARGUMENT TO
MAKING SURE PEOPLE GETTING PAID
NOW IF YOU DON'T LIKE TO LIGHT
THAT'S- YOU KNOW I CAN'T HELP
YOU THERE THAT'S NOT MY ISSUE
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
WE'RE TURNING AROUND SERVICES
QUICKLY. FOR CALIFORNIA SO I
FINALLY POINTED OUT BECAUSE YOU
WERE THE ONE WHO JUST SAID A
FEW MINUTES AGO THAT YOU HAVE A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS AND THIS IS
HOW YOU REVIEW YES AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A NON
COMPETITIVE. BIDS BUT BUT BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
EATING THE MAJORITY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN COMPETITIVE BID WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF THE ONES JUST
BUST RECENTLY. BUT DUE TO THE
CRISIS ON THE AND A PANDEMIC-
WE HAD TO TAKE EXTREME MEASURES
BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE THEM I MEAN
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE TO THE
PEOPLE THAT BUILT THE SYSTEM.
AND RIGHT YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S CURIOUS
ABOUT THIS ENTIRE SITUATION IS
AT DETROIT FOR THE BETTER PART
OF A DECADE. HAS HAD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR AGENCY
WHERE IT IS CONTINUE TO OVER
CHARGE UNDER THE LIVER AND
FRANKLY AND BET ITSELF AND
FURTHER LONG TERM DEPENDENCE
WITH WHAT HAS ANY BROKEN IT
SYSTEM AND SO. FOR THE BETTER
PART OF A TEN YEAR TEN YEARS
WE'VE WE'VE HAD THIS EXPERIENCE
AND YET IT HAS IT HAS CONTINUED
AND WHICH IS NOT ONE ASPECT OF
OUR PROCUREMENT PROCESS. GIVES
CREDIT TO THOSE VENDORS WHO
HAVE HAD LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIPS WITH GOVERNMENT
WHICH I THINK IS MADE IT
HARDER. FOR US TO EXTRICATE
OURSELVES FROM FROM THIS
RELATIONSHIP YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
CURIOUS SINCE I'VE BEEN DIGGING-INTO THIS I'VE LEARNED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT'S EXPERIENCE IN
WORKING ON UNEMPLOYMENT AND
OTHER STATES- YOU KNOW I'M
ASSUMING. THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FLORIDA
WITH DELIGHT. AND THEY'RE ON A
POINT SYSTEM. THE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR. HAD ORDERED INVEST.
INTO HOW THEIR STATE COULD HAVE
PAID SO. I PAID SO MUCH FOR SO
LITTLE. I'LL JUST QUOTE ONE
MORE LEFT IN THIS. DILUTES
TRACK RECORD IS CHECKERED WITH
NEGLIGENCE. PRODUCTS THAT WORK.
I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE ALSO
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS. AND
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
WHITE AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT
SYSTEM THERE. SO YOU KNOW I
GUESS. WE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS- HI YOU
KNOW IT MGHT BE APPROPRIATE TO
BRING TO LIGHT TO A FUTURE
HEARING. BECAUSE FROM OUR
STANDPOINT FOR THE BETTER PART
OF TEN YEARS. IT'S BEEN
GROUNDHOG DAY WE'VE SEEN THIS
MOVIE BEFORE. LITERALLY TEN
YEARS AGO. AND THERE'S BEEN
FAILURE AFTER FAILURE AFTER
FAILURE- I GUESS JUST TO END
THIS SECTION I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ASK- THE SECRETARY THE HEAD
OF THE STRIKE TEAM. MY HOPE IS
THAT YOU ARE ANALYZING. EDIE'S
CURRENT IT CONTRACTS AND-
REVIEWING THE PROCUREMENT AND
CONTRACTING PROCESS. AND AS WAS
MENTIONED FOR BY OUR COLLEAGUES
TO TALK TO OTHER. IT VENDORS AS
PART OF THE REVIEW BECAUSE-
ALONG WITH THAT ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER COUNTY BEACH NORTH. I'VE
CERTAINLY GOT AN AWFUL LOT OF
INTERESTING FEEDBACK. FROM
WITHIN GOVERNMENT AND OUTSIDE
OF GOVERNMENT. ABOUT HOW
CHALLENGING IT HAS BEEN. TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE LAWYER TO
ACTUALLY FIX EDT. AND I'M
HEARING THIS EVERY DAY. SO IT'S
JUST A IT'S A BIT BEFUDDLING TO
MAY- THAT EDT LEADERSHIP
CONTINUES TO DEFEND THAT
RELATIONSHIP WHEN IT CLEARLY
HAS NOT WORKED. AND IT'S COST
THE STATE. OVER A QUARTER
BILLION DOLLARS- LET ME LET ME
JUST AND BY. POINTING OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT. WE ARE
ALSO LOOKING FOR FEEDBACK FROM
SOAP. IN OUR LETTER WE. WE
MENTIONED A WHOLE NUMBER OF.
BASIC CUSTOMER SERVICE. WE'RE
HOPING SOME ANSWERS ON. WHETHER
IT'S WHETHER IT'S POSSIBLE TO
HAVE AUTOMATIC CALL BACK.
FEATURES ON YOUR CALL CENTER
HOW WE CAN PROVIDE WHICH
ACCESS. HOW DO WE ENSURE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE HANG UPS.
THAT AT THE LAST HEARING YOU
SAID YOU WERE. YOU'RE NOT HEARD
ABOUT BEFORE WHICH MY-
COLLEAGUES AND I HEAR ABOUT
EVERY DAY. HOW WE ANSWERED I
WILL APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HEAR PROPERLY LAST TIME YES I
HAVE HEARD THAT COMPLAINT AND-
WE CONTINUE TO DO TAKE MEASURES
ARE AROUND QUALITY ASSURANCE WE
TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY- SO-
LET ME JUST SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT THERE BECAUSE I JUST
DID NOT HEAR YOU CORRECTLY LAST
TIME. OCCURS WHAT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO CREATE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT AREA. A
NUMBER OF THINGS- WELL THAT'S
WHY WE- CAME UP WITH A
KNOWLEDGE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO
HELP PROVIDE A BETTER DATA. BUT
AND- WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
TRAINING- POLICY PROCEDURE
UPDATES NEWSLETTERS WE'RE ALSO
STARTING DISCUSSION WITH THE
UNION TO TALK ABOUT OUR ABILITY
TO LISTEN INTO CALLS SO WE
COULD DO CAUGHT REAL TIME
QUALITY ASSURANCE. SO THAT'S A
DISCUSSION THAT'S GOING ON- I
THINK THAT'S WHERE IT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE HELPFUL- YOU KNOW
WE CAN PROVIDE ALL THE TOOLS
MATERIALS BUT IN ORDER TO LOOP
AROUND TO DO THE COUNT ABILITY
M. WE REALLY NEED TO- HAVE OUR
MENTORS AND OUR MANAGERS BE
ABLE TO CALL AND- THAT JOB
LISTEN INTO SOME OF THE CALLS
AND HELP STAFF. WITH IMPROVING
ANY SERVICE ISSUES THERE MIGHT
BE. THAT IS GOOD TO HEAR LOOK
FORWARD GETTING MORE UPDATES ON
ON THAT- HAVE YOU HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANY OF YOUR-
WORKFORCE BOARDS AROUND THE
STATE WHO I KNOW. MANY OF WHOM
ARE DOING A LOT OF WORK OUTSIDE
EDT TO ASSESS THE SITUATION-
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT REGIONAL
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH. LOCAL
WORKFORCE BOARDS. WELL PART OF
OUR WORKFORCE SERVICES BRANCH-
AND THE- THE- THE BOARD- WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND- YOU KNOW
THAT'S PART OF WHAT I WAS
SAYING WORK WORKING ON TRYING
TO. MOVE PEOPLE THAT WE RE
DIRECTED TO YOU AYE BACK SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS AND A BIG
EMPHASIS IS IN OUR WORK FORCE
SERVICES BRANCH. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW AS WE START
PIVOTING TOWARDS UNEMPLOYMENT
TO REEMPLOYMENT WE NEED THEM-
OUT IN THE REGIONAL AREAS
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
WORKING WITH THE PARTNERS. AND
ESTABLISHING ALL NEW WAYS ON
HOW TO HELP PEOPLE GET BACK IN
FLOYD. SO ABSOLUTELY THAT'S A
VERY STRONG PARTNERSHIP THAT'S
THE WHOLE- WORK FIRST- HOW IT
OPERATES AS A PARTNERSHIP. I'M
NOT SURE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EXACTLY THE SAME THING BUT
THERE ASYOU PROBABLY KNOW
THERE'S A CONSOLATION OF WORKS
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS. THAT
WORK WITH CITY AND COUNTY AND
NONPROFIT AND PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS AND YEAH WHAT I HAVE
HEARD IS MANY OF THEM ARE
STRIVING AROUND THE CLOCK TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE. TO LOCAL
REGIONAL CONSTITUENTS ON DVD
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO WORK
MORE DEEPLY WITH YOUR AGENCY
AND FRANKLY JUST IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN CHALLENGING SO- I'D LOVE
TO GET AN UPDATE ON HOW THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING. ON
LISTEN. OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
MANY ASPECTS OF OUR LETTER THAT
WE HAVE NOT. HEARD RESPONSES ON
AND IT WOULD BE GREAT IF WE
COULD. RECEIVE SOME INFORMATION
ON THAT WRITTEN RESPONSES ON
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THE DIFFERENT PROPOSALS WE
HAVE. I THINK THE LAST THING I
pSECRETARY WHO'S HELPING TO HEAD
UP THE STRIKE FORCE TEAM. MY
REAL CONCERN ABOUT THE STRIKE
FOUR SEPARATE IS THAT IT'S
GOING TO AND- MID SEPTEMBER-
AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE THINKS
THAT WE CAN TURN THE TITANIC
AROUND. IN FORTY FIVE DAYS THE
EDT STRIKE FORCE WAS MODELED
AFTER. THE TURNAROUND REQUIRED
AT THE DMV WHICH TOOK SIX
MONTHS OF ENGAGEMENT. SO IF I
CANNOT A LOT TO ASK THE
SECRETARY- IF. SHE HAS THOUGHTS
ON. HOW TO ENSURE THAT AFTER
FORTY FIVE DAYS WHATEVER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE WILL TRULY
BE IMPLEMENTED TO CHANGE
PRACTICES. CULTURE IT SYSTEMS
AND SORT OF MOVE FOR LEADERSHIP
THAT THAT IMPLEMENTS SYSTEMIC
REFORM. AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
GREAT AND IF THERE'S NO ANSWER
TO THAT THIS MOMENT YOU KNOW IT
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'D LOVE
TO HEAR AND IN IN A COUPLE
WEEKS WHEN THAT REPORT COMES UP.
I WILL LEAD TO- IN ADDITION THE
STRIKE TEAM THAT'S WHY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM- MADE SURE THAT I HAVE.
THAT EXECUTIVE STAFF THAT I
NEED. LIKE I SAID I JUST
INTRODUCED CARL WILLIAMS A NEW
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR. OF
BEGINNING A SECOND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IN SEPTEMBER A GENERAL
COUNSEL IN SEPTEMBER. AS WELL
AS- A LEADS DIRECTOR JUST
STARTED. AND OR AGENCY- JUST
HIRED A ALLEGE POLICY PERSON TO
ASSISTANCE AS WELL. SO I'D I'M
GONNA SAY AGAIN I'M VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR ALL OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE GETTING- YOU
KNOW FRANKLY IT'S BEEN A
HANDFUL OF US SORT OF TRYING TO
KEEP. EVERYTHING AFLOAT AND-
YEAH IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THE
DIGITAL RESOURCES IN THE TEAM
THAT IS TRULY NEEDED. IN ORDER
TO MOVE THIS DEPARTMENT WHO'S
WHAT'S IS GOING TO BE. WELL
OVER TEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
NOW. TO THE NEXT LEVEL SO. I
IT'S GREAT WE'RE IN WE'RE GOING
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. GREAT AND
THE AB TWO TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
GO THEY'RE ABLE TO JOIN TEAM
AND PRE THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
STEP INTO. THESE THESE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES SO WITH
THAT MISTER. MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THE POINT OF- THAT
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
BY MY PREVIOUS TO COLLEAGUES
AND IT SURE AS WELL. BECAUSE
IT'S VERY SIMILAR BUT I WANTED
TO JUST FOCUS ON- FOR AREAS-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ONE IS-
I DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MR
CHU BRINGING UP THE SPECIFICS
OF THE NUMBERS I WAS LISTENING
TO THE NUMBERS YOU WERE
REPORTING. AND HOW IT'S GONE
DOWN FROM I BELIEVE THAT I EVEN
HEARD SIXTEEN MILLION AT SOME
POINT. DOWN TO FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION. BUT YOU KNOW THOSE
THOSE NUMBERS AS- GREAT AS THEY
ARE IN PROVIDING US. AN OVERALL
SENSE. THAT'S THE HEADLINE
THAT'S WHAT CAPTURES THE
HEADLINE. THEN IT'S THE REST OF
THE DETAILS THAT COUNT IN ORDER
FOR US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PRECISION IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES. IF I DON'T SEE WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE CALLS ARE
REPEAT CALLS. IF IT. I DON'T
KNOW HOW OTHER ASSEMBLY OR
SENATE OFFICES FUNCTION BUT
JUST IN OUR OFFICE WHAT I'D
LIKE STAFF TO DO IS EVERY TIME
A CONSTITUENT CALLS I WANT THAT
TO BE INPUT INTO OUR LCMS
SYSTEM. BECAUSE I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO KNOW WHAT EVERY SINGLE
CONSTITUENTS CONCERNED HAS BEEN.
IF I'M EVER GONNA SPEAK TO
THEIR CONSTITUENTS TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN THAT WE'VE HELPED THEM ON.
OF WHAT THEIR CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN AND WHAT THE GENERAL
THINKING IS. IF I'M DOING THAT
ON THE BASIS OF THE SMALL
OPERATION I HAVE AND I ONLY
HAVE TEN STAFFERS THAT CAN HELP
ME IN DOING THIS. AS A AND I
APOLOGIZE ACTUALLY FIVE
STAFFERS BECAUSE MY DISTRICT
OFFICE IS HOVERS BETWEEN FOUR
TO FIVE STAFFERS. I WOULD HAVE
EXPECTED THAT AN AGENCY LIKE
EDT. WOULD HAVE THE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE. TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE
ALL OF THIS DATA SO THAT YOU
CAN CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE. HOW
YOU'RE DELIVERING THOSE
SERVICES. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'RE JUST BEING KEPT IN THE
DARK. AS YOU'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH ISSUES. OR IF YOU
REALLY DON'T COLLECT THAT DATA
AND NOW YOU'VE STARTED JUST TO
HAVE TO COLLECT DATA BECAUSE
THERE WAS SERIES OF HARSH
QUESTIONS COMING YOUR WAY. BUT
YEAH THE DATA SUGGESTS
EVERYTHING IT COMMUNICATES
EVERYTHING IT HELPS RESOLVE
MANY ISSUES YOU KNOW THIS. SO
WHAT I WOULD PROPOSE IS AS
WE'RE HOLDING THESE HEARINGS I
WOULD ASK THE CHAIR AND THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE FOR US TO
ACTUALLY COME IN ON A MONTHLY
BASIS. EVEN WHEN WE'RE OUT OF
SESSION AND PREFERABLY IN.
PHYSICALLY BE HERE RATHER THAN
TO DO WITH THE RESUME CALL. TO
CONTINUE ASKING FOR QUESTIONS
AND MAYBE. OKAY I'M SORRY
CONTINUE TO GET UPDATES FROM
YOU BUT ALSO MAYBE WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU WITH QUICK
QUESTIONS MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ASKING FOR SO THAT ON A
MONTHLY BASIS WE GET THOSE
UPDATES. SO THAT. WE DON'T HAVE.
MISCOMMUNICATION OR MISSED
OPPORTUNITY SO EVERY MONTH WE
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
AND GETTING. THAT WOULD BE ONE
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
GOOD THANK YOU TO UNDER THE LAW
ISSUE I. WHAT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO KNOW IS DO YOU GET INVITED.
TO VARIOUS TECH COMPANIES OR
CONSULTANTS WOULD GO UP. DO YOU
GET INVITED TO TOWARDS OF
VARIOUS COMPANIES WHO PROVIDE
SERVICES. OR HAVE INTEGRATIVE
SYSTEMS THAT THEY OFFER AND
WORK WITH STATES TO. SEE WHAT
IS WHAT ADVANCEMENTS ARE TAKING
PLACE IN THE MARKET PLACE. HOW
DO OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD YOU
KNOW HOW MANY TOWARDS YOU'VE
GONE ON OR HOW MANY UP HOW MANY
DIFFERENT. PROGRAMS YOU'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTERACT WITH
OUR VISIT. IT FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF THE BENEFIT OF
SYSTEMS- WE DID EXTENSIVE-
MARKET RESEARCH AND- WE- MATT
WITH AND DID A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION AND MATT WHERE THAT
SAY ALL SEVEN EIGHT UP MAJOR
VENDORS IN THE U. Y. A. D. I.
ROUND. AND HAD- COMPREHENSIVE
OF DEMONSTRATIONS OF THEIR
SYSTEMS- AND THEN WHEN WE WENT
OUT TO BID WE MADE SURE THAT
ALL THOSE VENDORS THAT. THE OUT
THERE THEY WERE WELL AWARE OF
OUR PROCUREMENT AND- AT YOU
KNOW INVITED THEM TO BID. OUT
TO ENSURE WE HAD A GREAT POOL
OF VENDORS TO SELECT FROM- AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE DID
WE'RE JUST IN THE PROCESS OF
THE NARROWING IT DOWN AND HOPE
TO. YOU KNOW. COME UP WITH A
VENDOR SOON DIRECTOR OF
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WHICH I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT BUT AGAIN
BUT I'M TRYING TO ASK IS NOT
JUST WHEN YOU'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF. HAVING TO FIND A VENDOR. MY
QUESTION IS. AS TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES AS YOU MAINTAINING DATA
AND YOU SEE THAT THE NEEDS OF
YOUR AGENCY ARE CHANGING. THEE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPLORE
AND SEE WHAT PRODUCTS THERE ARE
IN THE MARKET SPACE AND HOW HOW
IT CAN BETTER HELP YOUR-
PROGRAMS VERSES THE ONE YOU MAY
BE EMPLOYING RIGHT NOW. SO WHAT
WHAT ARE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
AND I OBVIOUSLY I THINK I DON'T
WANT THE LEGISLATURE TO BE TRUE
ENGAGED IN SOME OF THAT PROCESS
BUT AGAIN AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
MANY OF THE PANELISTS HERE. WE
ARE APPROACHED AND WE ARE
OFFERED THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW
THINGS CAN IMPROVE AND SO WHAT
WHEN OU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS I SUSPECT THAT YOU GET
APPROACHED ON A MUCH MORE
FREQUENT BASIS. AND YET NONE OF
THOSE. APPROACHES HAVE YIELDED
A CHANGE IN WHO WE HAVE BEEN
EMPLOYING AS A STATE OR AS A
DEPARTMENT. IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS SO. SOMETHING HAS BEEN
VERY COMPELLING ABOUT THIS ONE
COMPANY. YET THEY HAVE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DELIVER. I'M JUST TRYING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND A- DO WE TAKE
FULL ADVANTAGE OF LEARNING AND
BEING OPEN TO WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE MARKET SPACE NOT JUST
DURING THE TIMES THAT WE'RE
EVALUATING A CONTRACT. TO IT'S
JUST INTERESTING TO ME WHY A
COMPANY THAT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO DELIVER CONTINUES TO BE
REWARDED BUT I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA BE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. SO. WOULD YOU
CARE TO COMMENT. YEAH SO WE USE
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT VENDORS
FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
SERVICES- THAT PRIOR CHAU- MET
WITH VENDORS EVERY MONTHS TO
LOOK AT THE LATEST- TECHNOLOGY
WHAT THEY THEY BRING- JUST IN
THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS WERE
USING DOCUSIGN WERE USING- AND
OUTSIDE VENDORS THROUGH C. D.
T. IN ODI RECOMMENDATION FOR
OUR CERTIFICATION REGISTER
VACATIONS- WE'VE GOT A WHOLE
HOST OF VENDORS I MEAN OUR
SYSTEM ISN'T JUST. WHAT THE
LATE BRING TO THE TABLE OUR
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE HOST OF A
BOLT ON SYSTEMS FROM NUMEROUS
VENDORS THAT MAKE IT ALL WORK
AND THAT'S PART OF THE BIG
PROBLEM I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN WITH THE LIGHT BUT I
WILL ALSO SAY THEY GAVE US THEY
BUILT A SYSTEM WHICH WAS A
BUILT ON SYSTEM BASED ON WHAT
AT THAT TIME. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WANTED TO DO AND
WHICH WAS ONLY DO A PARTIAL
REPLACEMENT I WOULD NEVER YOU
KNOW AT THAT TIME TECHNOLOGY
WISE I DON'T KNOW THAT WE THE
ENVIRONMENT WAS ACTUALLY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT A PARTIAL
REPLACEMENT DOES. BUT YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY YOU KNOW WHY WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALL THE WHOLESALE
REPLACEMENT TO MAKE SURE WE GET
AWAY FROM ALL THESE MULTAN'S-
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE TO PIECE
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO MAKE UP
THE U. I. SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE
EVERYTHING STAYS IN SYNC. SO
THEY. WERE GIVEN A TACIT WASN'T.
IN IN MY IT. PROBABLY THE BEST
STRATEGY BUT THAT'S WHAT WE
KNEW AT THE TIME OR THAT THE
LEAST THE LEADERS AT THE TIME.
THEY JUST THOUGHT THAT- DOING A
SMALLER TECHNOLOGY. ROSS SAYS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE SOLUTION WAS A
BETTER SITUATION THAN DOING A
WHOLE A WHOLE LIST OF CHANGE
AND I THINK WITH A LESSON
LEARNED WE'VE ALL LEARNED.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT THE WAY
TO GO YOU LOSE THE BENEFIT OF A
MODERNIZE SYSTEM THAT WORKS
HOLISTICALLY- AND THAT'S WHAT
WE DID WITH OUR TAX ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM AND OUR TAX AREA. WE DID
A WHOLESALE REPLACEMENT AND WE
SEEN THE BENEFITS OF IT AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY WE WERE
LOOKING TO DO IT FOR OUR
BENEFITS SYSTEM SO WE CAN. HAVE
THE SAME SUCCESS IN OUR BENEFIT
ROUND THAT WE HAD IN OUR TAX
AROUND. SO ANYWAY YES WE'RE
WE'RE USING IDEALIZING VENDORS
ALL THE TIME THEIR NEW
INNOVATIONS AND- SCREENING THE
MARKET- I KNEW CHAU- TO START
IN MARCH IS- FANTASTIC. AND IT
BROUGHT EVEN MORE AND MORE
IDEAS TO THE TABLE- WHICH HAS
BEEN VERY EXCITING. BUT YEAH.
TO LAST I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU
A LITTLE WHILE AGO WHEN YOU
WERE ANSWERING ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS- HE SAID THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE A QUESTION
ABOUT. WHAT WE LOOK LIKE MOVING
FORWARD. AND SO I WANT TO ASK
YOU. GIVEN ALSO THESE NUMBERS
GIVEN ALSO ALL THE HIRINGS THAT
YOU ARE CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A VERY.
THERE'S BEEN A DELAYED RAMP UP
AND A LOT OF THE CONCERNS HAVE
HAVE THAT. HAVE LED TO NOW THIS
RAMP UP WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE YOU WOULD HAVE HOPED
THAT THE DEMAND WOULD HAVE BEEN
MET. BUT THERE'S BEEN A DELAY
VERY DELAYED MEETING OF THE
DEMAND AND THERE'S BEEN QUITE A
BIT OF HIRING OF NEW STAFF. NOW
AT SOME POINT AS THE CONCERNS
DECRESCENDO AND THAT MIGHT BE.
SOMETIME AWAY BECAUSE I THINK
THE WORST OF THIS RECESSION IS
YET TO HIT. WHAT IS. WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR EDT MOVING
FORWARD ARE WE JUST GOING TO
HAVE A HIGHER LOAD OF EMPLOYEES
IS IT ALL GOING TO SUBSIDE AT
SOME POINT OR WHAT DOES THE
AGENCY LOOK LIKE AND THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN ONGOING COMIC THIS
IS GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION BUT I FEEL LIKE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BRING IT UP
BECAUSE- WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE-
OF THE SHORTNESS. OF THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS LIMITS. TERM
LIMITS. OR WHATEVER ELSE IS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR- IT IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE ISSUES. THE
EIGHT INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY
SUPPORTS THERE BEING LONG TERM
DISCUSSIONS OF HOW THE ISSUES
GET RESOLVED. SO IF ANYTHING I
WANT THIS TO BE THE START TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU TELL US
WHAT YOU WANT TO LOOK LIKE AND
LAST TIME WE ESTABLISHED YOU
YOU'VE BEEN. EVEN WITH THIS
INSTITUTION A VERY LONG TIME SO
HOW WHERE ARE THE CHANGES YOU
SEE. THAT NEEDS TO BE
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE AGENCY
MOVING FORWARD. I WOULDN'T MIND
IF YOU OFFER SOME THOUGHTS
RIGHT NOW AND WE CAN CONTINUE
TALKING. DEFINITELY I MEAN AT
WHAT I'D LOVE TO SEE THE CUT
THE CALL CENTER BE RESPONDING
TO EVERYBODY THAT NEEDS HELP. I
WOULD LOVE TO USE EVERY FEATURE
IN TECHNOLOGY THERE IS OUT
THERE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
DIFFERENT- VEHICLES AND AVENUES
FOR SERVICE. I LIKE ALL OF OUR
INFORMATION TO BE IS CLEAR AND
UNDERSTANDABLE AND DIGESTIBLE
BY ALL WHICH IS IT A HUGE
CHALLENGE GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE FEDERAL PROGRAM. IT JUST
SEEMS TO GET MORE AND MORE
COMPLEX. SO I'D YOU KNOW I WANT
TO BE A DIRECTOR OF A
DEPARTMENT WHERE MY STAFF. ARE
SO PROUD OF THE SERVICES WERE
PROVIDING BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'RE
GIVING THAT TOP NOT SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIANS. THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED TO BE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THE HELP
OF A CD T. ODI THE STRIKE TEAM.
THE GOVERNOR ADDITIONAL
APPOINTEES- IT TAKES MANPOWER
AND IT TAKES- GOOD PEOPLE AT
THE TABLE TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND THE WILLINGNESS TO
FIND IT. SO I THINK YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT GOOD THAT WERE IN THE
LIMELIGHT BUT BEING IN THE
LIMELIGHT DOES A PRESENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREAT GREAT
IMPROVEMENT. SO MAYBE THAT'S
NOT THE WAY YOU WANT TO DO IT
BUT IT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY STRIVE AND MAKE CHANGES
AND GREAT PARTNERSHIP SO. I
WELCOME IT. WE NEED TO BE
DIFFERENT. MY COMMENTS ARE
PARTIALLY BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
ONCE BEFORE AND I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT I THINK MOST OF US
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT WHAT
ARE STATE WAS CHALLENGED WITH
OVER A LITTLE OVER TEN YEARS
AGO. WOULD HAVE PREPARED US IN
DEALING WITH WHAT. THE
ONSLAUGHT OF WHAT HAPPENED THIS
YEAR. AND WE WERE EXTREMELY ILL
PREPARED AND SO- IT. OBVIOUSLY
YOU ARE IN THE LIMELIGHT. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME. IT MOVING
FORWARD I WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT
IS. THIS I'M GLAD THAT THE
STRIKE FORCE IS GONNA HELP BUT
YOU AS AN INDIVIDUAL AS THE
HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT AND AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT FOR A VERY LONG TIME
THE SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN WITH THE
STATE FOR A VERY LONG TIME. I'D
BE INTERESTED TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
AND I'M HAPPY TO. FOR IT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU START
DISCUSSING YOU REVEAL AT OUR
NEXT HEARING SO THAT MOVING
FORWARD WE KNOW WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE. TOUCH TO MAKE
APPROPRIATE IMPLEMENT CHANGES
AND IMPLEMENTATIONS IN PLACE
YEAH SO WITH THAT THANK YOU CAN
START ONE I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ONE THING AS FAR AS OUR
PREPAREDNESS I'M GOING INTO
WHEN THE PANDEMIC CARE ACT. IF
WE WEREN'T WHERE WE WERE- IN
FEBRUARY WITH ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES ENHANCEMENT
OF COMMUNICATION IMPROVEMENTS
THERE IS NO WAY WE WOULD'VE
MADE THE PAYMENTS WE'VE BEEN
MAKING IF WE WORSE IF WE LOOK
LIKE WE DID TEN YEARS AGO. WE
WOULD HAVE IMPLODED THERE IS NO
WAY WE COULD PROVIDE THE
SERVICE THAT THAT YOU'RE
GETTING ON YOU MAY NOT LOVE THE
LEVEL I DON'T BUT- AT THE SAME
TIME WITH PAID OUT BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE TIP TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT NEED IT. SO
YES- WERE WE READY TO BE HIT BY
A PANDEMIC NO BUT WHO US AND-
YOU KNOW AGAIN WE MADE SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS THE ONLY
REASON WE ARE SURVIVING IS FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE DONE.
THE LAST TEN YEARS SO. YEAH I
WAS GONNA LEAVE IT AT THAT LAST
COMMENT BUT GIVEN THAT YOU SAID
THIS MISS HILLARD. I CAN NAME
YOU. BY FIRST NAMES. MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE CALLED
WHO. I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT
WE'VE ALREADY HELPED. AND YET
THEY'RE CALLING BACK AGAIN.
SAYING THAT EVEN AFTER OUR
INITIAL HELP AND THEIR INITIAL
PAYMENT THEY'RE STILL FALLING
INTO A AREA WHERE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE SUPPORT NEEDED
MOVING FORWARD SO RIGHT WHEN
YOU TELL ME THAT. THESE
PROBLEMS WE'RE IN A BETTER
PLACE THAT THESE PROBLEMS WERE
ADDRESSED WHY IS IT THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHERE OUR OFFICES
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN.
PROMOTING THEIR ISSUE. AND
BRINGING IT TO THE FOREFRONT
ARE STILL CONTINUING TO HAVE
PROBLEMS SO YOU CAN JUST
IMAGINE AND IT'S NOT JUST ME
SAYING THIS WHEN YOU HEAR IT
FROM MULTIPLE PEOPLE IT REALLY
ERODES THE CONFIDENCE. ON BUT
YOU'RE BASING YOUR- ARGUMENTS.
I TOTALLY HEAR YOU AND I AGREE
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE SO I'M JUST
IN THE MASS. WHAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH HAS BEEN-
QUITE INCREDIBLE BUT IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH WE KNOW THAT AND-
OUR SYSTEMS NEED TO BE A WHOLE
NEW LEVEL. BUT I AGREE. WOOD
MISTER NAZARIAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE. I
DON'T THINK ALL THE PANELS FOR
THE PARTICIPATION. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ANY PUBLIC SPEAKERS
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THE TOPIC. PLEASE GO FORWARD.
YOU'RE NOT HOT YET COULD LIKE
TURN ON PLEASE.
OKAY GREAT GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE NAVNEET BEEN
DAHLE ON BEHALF OF S. LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND WE REPRESENT MEMBERS
WHO WORK AT E. D. D. WHO WANTED
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT OVER
THE PHONE. BUT SINCE THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE THEY ASKED THAT I
COME HERE AND STAND. MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE WORKING TWELVE
HOUR SHIFTS AND ON WEEKENDS TO
PROCESS THE HISTORIC LEVEL A
DELIGHT CLAIMS INCLUDING THE
CLAIMS OF YOUR MEMBERS. FOR
YEARS NOW WE'VE BEEN RAISING
THE ALARM BELLS REGARDING UNDER
STAFFING AND OUTDATED
TECHNOLOGY AT ET D. WITHOUT ANY
REAL ANSWERS. UNFORTUNATELY A
TOOK A PANDEMIC TO GET THE BALL
ROLLING. AS MUCH AS PEOPLE WALK
PAST SOLUTIONS WE KNOW
CONTRACTING OUT DOES NOT WORK.
EIGHT YEAR OLD LOW PERFORMING
WORKERS. WHO ARE UNDER TRAINED
AND UNDERPAID THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- VERSION OF FOR THE
SPEAKERS IN THE ROOM I'M TOLD
ON THE PHONE LINES IN THE
REMOTE ROOM THERE ARE NO PUBLIC
SPEAKERS- SO THAT DRAWS TO A
CONCLUSION YOU KNOW I'M SOMEONE
ENCOURAGED BY SOME OF THE STEPS
TAKEN BUT WE STILL A LONG WAYS
TO GO- WE PUT A HAVING HEARING
NEXT MONTH WILL REACH OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO SEE WHETHER WE- DO
IT HERE- ZOOM I THINK.
SEMESTERS THERE IN AND THANK A
HEARING HERE IS MUCH MORE
IMPACTFUL THAN DOING SOON SO
WE'LL REACH OUT SEE WHAT THE
COVERING DO IT ANYWAYS- THANK
YOU ALL AND HAVE A GOOD DAY
THIS MEETINGS ADJOURNED.